Programming Throwdown Episode 183 Landing a Software Job in 2025. Take it away, Jason. Yeah. Hey, everybody. So, okay, so we pushed an episode out last. last month, that was about AI-assisted coding. And a lot of people reached out to me, emailed me personally on LinkedIn or some comments.
Programming Throwdown 第 183 期：2025 年软件行业求职指南。Jason，开始吧。好的。嘿，大家好。那么，我们上个月发布了一期关于 AI 辅助编程的节目。很多人联系我，通过 LinkedIn 私信我，或者在评论区留言。
A lot of people reached out with questions, with, you know, asking. I actually met several people I did a Zoom call with who are asking for help, you know, landing their first job. So since that episode of met, I think, three or four people over Zoom. And so it really gave a ton of feedback. like it had a big impact and um you know as i was looking at the the show statistics which to be honest i never really do but this will kind of prove it i was thinking wow you know this episode seemed to resonate with people but you know we had less downloads than the last time i checked which was about a year or two ago and then i realized back then we were doing two three shows a month
很多人发来问题，或者说，寻求建议。我实际上和几个人进行了 Zoom 通话，他们都在寻求帮助，希望能找到第一份工作。所以自那期节目以来，我想我通过 Zoom 见了三四个人。这真的提供了大量的反馈，感觉影响很大。而且，当我查看节目统计数据时——老实说，我平时从不看这个，但这正好证明了这一点——我在想，哇，这期节目似乎引起了大家的共鸣，但下载量却比我上次查看时（大约一两年前）要少。然后我意识到，那时候我们一个月做两三期节目。
and so what that means is we actually hit like more than double the the volume of people or the audience size was actually more than double for that episode. And that showed me that, you know, there is real interest here. And, you know, Patrick and I have, you know, we're pretty senior in our careers. And so, you know, I thought, who's a person who could really give good advice to people who are in college, just getting out of college? And that's what made me think of Mark, a good friend of mine over here in Austin. and Mark, why don't you kind of introduce yourself a bit and tell us like kind of a bit
这意味着我们那期节目的受众规模实际上是平时的两倍多。这向我表明，这里确实存在真正的需求。而且，Patrick 和我在职业生涯中已经相当资深了。所以我在想，谁能给那些在读大学生或刚毕业的学生提供好的建议呢？这让我想到了 Mark，我在奥斯汀的一位好朋友。Mark，你能不能简单介绍一下自己，告诉我们一些关于你的背景？谢谢。我有幸拥有一个非常紧密的团队。我们是一家三人制的猎头公司。虽然从未刻意规划，但我非常有幸多年来一直有像 Jason Gouchy 和 Patrick Wheeler 这样顶尖 1% 的工程领导者来找我，说：“Mark，帮我找个软件工程师。”所以，我的团队成员 Troy Rudolph 和 Caleb Guerin，他们都非常出色。我们实际上已经花了数十年时间，不断地与顶尖 1% 的软件工程师建立联系，为他们提供机会。我们共同经营着这个市场。在正式的招聘流程中，我们只做应急招聘。因此，只有当我们成功完成招聘时，公司才会支付报酬。
about your background. Thank you. So I've got the good fortune. I've got this incredibly close team. We're a three-person technical recruiting firm. And it was never done strategically, but I've had the very good fortune of top 1% executive engineering leaders like a Jason Gouchy and like a Patrick Wheeler that have come to me through the years, Mark, find me a software engineer. So, and my team as they've joined me, who is Troy Rudolph and Caleb Guerin. They're both incredible. We've spent decades, literally, reaching out to top 1% software engineers with opportunities. And we're just kind of, we network that market together. In the formal sense of running searches, we do contingency only. So in that manner, a company compensates us only if we make a placement
（续上）对于那些极难找到职位的需求。我们的业务区域主要是奥斯汀、纽约市、湾区、亚特兰大等地。我们的品牌完全是靠对各方提供谦逊的服务建立起来的。所以我们从未试图扩张。很多人曾给我施压，希望我扩大这家猎头公司的规模并将其出售。但如果我那样做，我该干什么呢？我会过得很痛苦。
for very hard to find rules. Our demographics have been, geographies rather, have been Austin, in New York City, the Bay Area, Atlanta, and such. And the brand has just been built through a modest sense of service to other parties and whatnot. So we've never tried to grow. I've taken a lot of heat from people. They want me to try to scale this recruiting firm and oh and sell it. And what the hell am I going to do, right? I do miserable.
所以，我们很享受现在所做的事情。这是一种对各方（包括初创公司甚至当地的老牌企业）真正的服务。是的，我们是一家技术猎头公司。太棒了。那么你是如何进入这个领域的？你的整个职业生涯都是猎头吗？或者你是怎么开始的？哇，你一定会喜欢这个故事。我有幸——我不认为你们俩有过这种经历，虽然你们年轻时也曾有过挣扎的时刻——但在我 20 多岁时，我过得很糟糕。我当时是棕榈滩岛的一名代客泊车员。我记得有一次我甚至停过 Jeffrey Epstein 的车。但我渴望进入白领阶层。于是我从佛罗里达搬到了德克萨斯，在圣马科斯的德克萨斯州立大学读了一个非认证的 MBA 项目。但你猜怎么着？我走在校园里，看到一家猎头公司在招技术猎头，那是 1995 年，因为他们的老板提到软件工程行业在德克萨斯州奥斯汀地区开始兴起。我在其他地方找不到工作。
So, but we enjoy what we're doing. It's a true sense of service to another party, which are startups and even established firms here in town. But yeah, we're a technical recruiting firm. That's awesome. So how did you personally get kind of started in this space? Have you been a recruiter for your whole career or how did that start for you? Wow, you're going to love it. I had the good fortune and I don't think it's something either one of you guys. Well, y'all have had moments when you were younger when you were struggling. But in my mid-20s, I was doing really poorly. I was a valet on Palm Beach Island. I believe one time I actually parked Jeffrey Epstein's car. But I wanted to get into white collar employment. And so I moved from Florida to Texas, and I got a non-accredited MBA program, MBA from Texas State University in San Marcos. But how about this? I'm walking down the campus, and I see a recruiting firm looking for technical recruiters, 1995, because their owners had mentioned that software engineering profession was starting to boom in the Austin, Texas area. I couldn't find a job elsewhere.
我当时有三个选择：一个是德克萨斯州政府提供的管理棉花产量的职位；另一个是在德克萨斯州韦科的一个卡车休息站工作，负责凌晨 12 点到早上 8 点的轮班，给 18 轮大卡车加油。所以我有这三个选择：技术猎头、管理棉花交付，以及在卡车休息站工作。我选择了猎头职位。这时间点选得太好了，因为我当时迫切需要一份工作。于是我在 1995 年一头扎进了奥斯汀的猎头行业。天哪，那就像 1972 年跳进湾区，
I had an offer from the state of Texas to manage cotton volume that are produced here in Texas. And then I had a job at a truck stop up in Waco, Texas to work the midnight to 8 a.m. shift when 18 wheelers come in and get them gassed up. So I had those three options, technical recruiter managing cotton deliverables and working at a truck stop. So I take the recruiting role. But how about timing? because I desperately needed something. So I dove into it into Austin, Texas in 1995. Damn, that's like jumping into the Bay Area in 1972,
抓住了年轻的 Steve Jobs 和他的几个招聘经理，而你甚至都不知道他们有招聘需求。所以我很幸运地踏入了这一行。我在 1999 年创办了自己的公司。正如你们俩所知，当你为特定人群提供服务时——在我们的案例中，是奥斯汀顶尖 1% 的软件工程师——你自然会为自己建立起一个相当不错的品牌。
getting a hold of a young Steve Jobs and a couple of his hiring managers have hiring needs and you don't even know it. So I had the good fortune of stepping into something. I started my own firm in 1999. And again, as both of you well know, when you provide a sense of service to particular demographics, In our case, the top 1% software engineers in Austin, you kind of build a pretty good brand for yourself.
这就是我们所做的。在这些艰难时期，许多猎头公司都倒闭了。但我们很幸运，我们做得还不错。确实。太棒了。所以我想，我们都同意现在是艰难时期。
And that's just kind of what we do. And in these tough times, a lot of recruiting firms have gone out of business. But we've got the good fortune. We're doing pretty well. Shoot. Yeah. That's awesome. So I think, yeah, we all kind of agree that these are tough times.
但这里存在一个悖论，你看到有些人拿到了价值数亿美元的录用通知。那么你如何调和这一点呢？外面到底发生了什么？而且这只针对极少数人。我们最近与一位机器学习工程师合作，我必须对他在奥斯汀的身份保密。有几家公司都在争抢他。哇，Apple 加入了竞争，给了他一笔惊人的薪水。他才 28 岁，可以说下半辈子衣食无忧了。这是一个有趣的动态。但另一方面，我们也在努力帮助那些受影响的软件工程师，有些软件工程师已经失业五到六个月了。
But there is this paradox where you see people getting like a tenth of a billion dollar offer. And so how do you kind of reconcile? that. Like, what is going on out there? And it is only for the smallest amount. We did, we recently worked with the machine learning engineer. I have to keep his name confidential here in Austin. And we had a couple of firms jumping after him. Wow, Apple stepped in and dropped some crazy cash on him. He's 28 years old. He's kind of set for life. So that is a little, that's interesting dynamic. But then on the other hand, we are also working. We want to help impacted software engineers there are software engineers who have been out of work five to six months.
从技术上讲，在当前的软件工程行业，如果你的技能水平从 99.5% 下滑到 97%，技术评估就会识别出这种下滑。你可能就无法进入现场面试环节。这是目前受到严格审查的另一个方面。所以，是的。哇。哇。
And technically their skills of, right now in the software engineering profession, if your skills go from 99.5 percent bound to about 97, that technical assessment will recognize that, that slip. And you might not make it to the onsite. That's another thing that's being scrutinized really hard right now. So, yeah. Wow. Wow.
是的，我们会深入探讨所有这些问题。但在进入正题之前，Mark Cunningham，非常感谢你。我对此感到非常兴奋。我对此充满期待。如果你在当地，或者如果他能帮到你，Mark 是个很棒的人。我认为你绝对应该联系他。我真的很兴奋能做这期节目。
Yeah, we will dive into all of that. But before we get into that, Mark Cunningham, Thank you so much in advance. I'm really excited about this. I'm pumped about this. Mark is a great guy if you are in the area or if, you know, if, you know, he could help you. I think you should definitely reach out to him. I'm really excited to do this.
那么让我们开始吧。第一步是找工作。也许我可以先开个头，因为我对此有非常非传统的看法。我有一个大胆的观点。我很想听听 Patrick 和 Mark 的看法。我觉得今天你不能真的在网上申请工作。我简单介绍一下我的背景。
So let's jump into it. The first step is finding a job. Maybe I can kick it off because I have very unorthodox take on this. I have a hot take on this. And I'd love to hear Patrick and Mark, your opinions on this. I feel like today you can't really apply for a job online. I'll give you kind of my very quick background.
我获得第一份工作是通过朋友介绍的。我在洛克希德马丁公司有个朋友，他说，嘿，这里是个有趣的地方。我还有一些在其他公司的朋友。所以总是会有朋友推荐一些地方。我面试了几家公司，但我并没有主动去寻找它们。诚然，这意味着我可能错过了一些机会。但也意味着我从未真正体验过那种把简历
The way I got into my first job was through a friend. So I have a friend at Lockheed and he said, hey, this is like an interesting place. I had some friends out of some other companies. And so there's always kind of friends who suggested places. And then I interviewed at a few places, but I didn't seek any of them out. And admittedly, that probably meant I left some places on the table. But it also meant that I've never really experienced just like throwing my resume
匿名投递给公司的情况。从那以后，基本上都是通过朋友，或者在 Meta 的时候，Meta 是亲自联系我的。当时我对现有的工作很满意，但他们联系了我，那是一个非常有趣的机会。这并不是我们现在听到的那些录用通知。那是十年前的事了。所以，我从未像那样申请过工作，比如勾选方框、匿名上传 PDF。我觉得这根本行不通。但 Mark，你对此有什么看法？你是怎么找到工作的？好的。你是对的。我同意。盲目地向公司投递简历是行不通的。我很喜欢你用的“朋友”这个词。在我们的职业生活中，朋友的定义可能与个人生活中不同。我有高中和大学的哥们，但我绝不会指望他们帮我找工作。你知道，有一次，这算朋友吗？我曾经帮助过
anonymously at a company. And then from there, it's always, it's pretty much always been either friends or in I did have a situation where at Meta, so Meta reached out to me personally and, you know, and I was content at my current job, but, you know, they reached out to me and it was a really interesting opportunity. And this isn't, this isn't, these offers we're hearing about now. This is a decade ago. But, so I have never applied, you know, just like check the box, uploaded my PDF anonymously. And I feel like it doesn't. really work. But Mark, what's your kind of take on that? Like, how do you find the job? Okay. You're right. I agree. Blindly applying to companies doesn't work. And then I loved your word friend. And in our professional lives, the definition of friend can be different from personal. I've got buddies from high school and college, but I would never rely on them to try to help me find a job. You know, one time, is this a friend? How about this? I had helped
Nate Foreman。他是 Hotel Engine 的一位杰出领导者。我曾经帮助过他父亲，他在 IBM 工作得很好。我试着帮他找工作。我还帮过他的另一位亲戚。后来有一次，他去了亚马逊的人力资源副总裁那里，他说：“嘿，把 Mark Cunningham 加到供应商名单里。”于是，亚马逊就这么做了。这是在奥斯汀的亚马逊业务。那么 Nate Foreman 是朋友吗？我称 Nate Foreman 为兄弟。对于他所做的一切，他就像我的家人一样。所以软件工程师们，当你们开始新的求职时，无论你的级别如何，都要找出一些了解你素质、了解你作为工程师能力的人，他们可能会为你游说，可能会把你的简历递给招聘经理并为你背书，建立那个网络。这需要精心策划。花一个周末的时间，从你的大学时代找起，甚至找五到六个同事。你们俩可能都有九到十个同事，你会愿意去他们公司的执行团队说：“哇，一定要和这个人谈谈，他非常有才华。我一直很喜欢
Nate Foreman. He's an incredible leader over at Hotel Engine. And I one time helped his dad who had a great run at IBM. I tried to help him on a search. He had another relative I helped. And then he one time went to the VP of HR at Amazon. And he said, hey, put Mark Cunningham on the vendor list. And so, and Amazon did that. It's Amazon business here in Austin. So is Nate Foreman a friend? Nate Foreman, I call him brother. He's like a family to me for what he did. So software engineers, as you start, start a new job search, no matter your rank, identify some people that know something about your qualities, what you can do as an engineer, who would maybe lobby for you, would maybe take your resume and put it in front of the hiring manager and endorse you, build that network. So that takes some curating. Spend a weekend to find from your college days, maybe even two, or five to six coworkers. Both of you probably have upwards of maybe nine to 10 co-workers that you would go to the executive team at the company you work out and say, wow, got to talk to this person, very talented. I've always enjoyed
和他们一起工作。”这种背书确实有帮助。所以这是第一件要做的事。如果你在一家公司工作，而你所在地区有类似行业的公司，比如医疗技术在奥斯汀很火，你也可以瞄准这些公司。你可以提交简历，让他们知道你非常了解医疗技术领域。还有一件事，我一直在建议软件工程师，
working with them. And then that endorsement does contribute. So that's the first thing to do. If you work at a company that has similar firms of a similar industry in your same area, like healthcare technology is pretty hot here in Austin, you can target those as well. and you can present your resume. You can let them know that you understand the healthcare technology space really well. And then another thing, I've been advising software engineers,
去 LinkedIn 上邀请那些公司的招聘副总裁甚至 CTO 建立联系，说：“嘿，我最近向贵公司提交了简历，我非常看好这个机会。我只是想联系一下。祝你今天愉快。”
go ahead and invite to connect with the VPs of talent at those companies on LinkedIn or maybe even the CTO and say, hey, I recently submitted my resume to your company, I think very highly of the opportunity. I just want to reach out and connect. Hey, have a great day ahead.
这通常会被接受。它不能保证面试，但比盲目投递要好，因为我知道很多优秀的软件工程师，他们每天投递 25 到 30 份申请，却一无所获。找到相关的公司，列出一份六到七个愿意为你背书的人的名单。然后还可以寻找相关的公司，比如金融科技、医疗技术、房地产科技。你知道，城里有 realtor.com，还有 set point。是的，这很有道理。
And that's often accepted. It's not going to guarantee an interview, but it's better than just cold applying because, yeah, I know a lot of great software engineers. They're sending out 25 to 30 applications a day and they're getting nothing. Find relevant companies curate a list of six to seven people that would endorse you to that company. And then also find maybe related firms, fintech, healthcare technology, real estate tech. You know, there's realtor.com in town and there's also set point. Yeah, that makes sense.
我想如果你没有那个朋友圈，我觉得下一个最好的办法是通过 Meetup 等地方建立那个朋友圈，在那里你可以建立人脉。天哪，好观点。而且在软件工程领域和你的领域，Jason，你建立的朋友并不是在欢乐时光喝啤酒时认识的，也许有几个人是，但更多是因为你提供的解决方案。
I think if you if you don't have that friend group, I think maybe the next best thing is is building that friend group through things like Meetup and other places where you can network. Damn, good point. And again, in the software engineering space and your space, Jason, the friends you've developed haven't been at happy hours, having beers, maybe a couple of folks, but it's a solution you've provided.
然后整个团队都认可了这一点，每个人都说：“天哪，是 Jason 的代码让这一切发生的。”然后你就收获了五个终身的朋友。我要做一个小小的补充。我认为，在许多大型公司工作过之后，我觉得小型企业、中型企业和大型企业之间确实存在差异。但在大型企业工作时，有针对性的大学招聘、
And then the whole team got recognized for it. and everyone goes, damn, it was Jason's code that made that shit happen. And then those are five friends that you just picked up for life. I'll make a slight addendum, I'll say. I think there is having worked at a number of large firms. And I think there is a difference between like really small places, medium size, and then like large corporations or whatever. But I think working at large corporations, there is a targeted university,
大学关系和大学目标定位。所以如果你确实去了传统的四年制大学、硕士或博士项目，直接投递到空白框或者参加校园招聘活动是有意义的。有一种特殊的处理方式，我认为你可以获得更多的关注，
university relations, university targeting. So if you do go to a traditional four-year, you know, master's degree, PhD, there is something to just applying to the blank box or at your, you know, recruiting event on your campus. There is like special handling where I think you can get more traction
因为这可能有点像，“好吧，我还在上学，我真的没有可以为我的工作担保的人。”我认为在某些特殊情况下，这种方法是可行的。不过，回到你们的观点，通过朋友申请，为了让大家知道，在大型公司，有两个层面。一个是给朋友一份简历。
because it can be a bit like, well, I'm in school. I don't really have people who can vouch for my work. And I think there is like some amount of special cases where that can work. And then to, to your guys' point, though, applying with a friend, though, just so people know, again, at large companies, there's two levels. There's giving a friend a resume.
然后当他们提交时，他们会问：“你认识这个人吗？你有多了解这个人？”我想 Mark 提到的就是背书。所以有两个层面。请人投递简历并不是什么大障碍，因为他们通常只是把它提交到内部系统，这可能会增加一点点权重。但如果他们愿意写下任何关于为你担保、为你技术能力背书的评论，那么它就提升到了一个新的水平，你基本上解锁了
And then when they put it in, they're going to say, do you know this person? How well do you know this person? I think Mark kind of referred to as like endorsement. So there are two levels. Asking someone to put your resume in really isn't that big of a hurdle because they normally just submit it to the internal box, which probably adds a little extra juice. But if they're willing to write a comment at all about like some vouching for you, your technical capabilities, then it takes it to a new level where you're sort of unlocking that
至少有人会看它，尝试和你谈谈，尝试把它放在某人面前。所以这里有不同的层面和细微的差别。所以一概而论有点困难，但绝对的建议是，如果可以的话，通过你认识的人的渠道去联系肯定更好，但有时在某些情况下，其他方法也确实有效。是的，这很有道理。还有，你知道，关于这个有个笑话，Reddit 社区无所不包，无论它多么深奥，
at least someone's going to look at it, you know, try to talk to you, try to put it in front of someone. And so there are kind of like levels there and slight division. So a blanket statement is a little hard, but no, absolutely the advice is if you can, going through those channels of people you know, reaching out is definitely better, but there can be times and situations where other stuff does work. Yeah, that makes sense. Also, like, you know, there's kind of like a joke about this that there's like a Reddit community for everything like no matter how esoteric it is
都有一个 Reddit 社区。但我认为，如果你真的非常非常热衷于，比如说强化学习，你把所有的清醒时间都花在上面，并且你让自己被
there's a Reddit community for it but I think that like you know if you're really really into let's just say reinforcement learning and you just spend all your waking hours about it and you surround yourself
其他对它感兴趣的人包围，无论是在线还是线下，那个网络实际上比你想象的要小。如果很多公司需要你感兴趣的东西，那么你网络中的某个人很有可能在你想工作的公司找到了一份工作。所以听起来好像是，“哦，我有五个朋友。其中一个想雇我或者公司想雇我的几率是多少？”但我猜，在专门研究你所擅长领域的社区里，五个朋友可能已经很多了。
with other people who are interested in it either online in person all of the above that network is actually smaller than you think And if a lot of companies need that thing that you're interested in, chances are somebody in your network is going to get a job at a place that you want to work at. So it sounds like, oh, I have five friends. What are the odds that one of them wants to hire me or is that a company wants to hire me? But I guess like five actually might be a lot in the community that kind of specializes and what you specialize in.
对于我们年轻的软件工程师来说，在 22 到 27 岁之间建立关系具有不可思议的价值，这样他们的同事就会去找你们中的任何一个人并为他们背书。这很简单，他们应该和他们谈谈。我的意思是，天哪，Jason，你可以想象任何人，Patrick，你也一样，如果我把任何人推荐给你们，并提供一次咖啡会面，哇，这对我来说很大胆。你必须自动假设这个人是个狠角色。而且他们不会试图向你推销多层次营销之类的东西。好的，那么，假设你通过了第一道关卡。现在 IBM 的一位招聘人员——我们应该用一家公司举例，因为我们将不断讨论面试过程。
For our young software engineers, there's just incredible value that they build relationships between 22 and 27 years old to where their coworkers would go to either one of you and endorse them. That's simple that they should talk to them. I mean, damn, Jason, you can imagine anyone, and you too, Patrick, if I refer anyone to y'all and offer up a coffee meeting, wow, that's bold on my end. you've got to automatically assume the person's a badass. And they're not going to try to sell you multi-level marketing and whatever. Okay, so you, let's say you get past that first hurdle. And now a recruiter from, we should use a company. Let's just say IBM, because we're going to be constantly talking about the interview process.
假设你在 IBM 面试。IBM 的一位招聘人员正在联系你，他们想和你通电话。我会给出我的建议，关于如何从最初的电话筛选，也许还有技术电话筛选，过渡到一场成功的面试。然后我们再进行类似的圆桌讨论。我看到很多人觉得他们想利用自己的主动权来获得最好的面试机会。举个例子：我的背景是强化学习，如果有人开始问我关于支持向量机的问题，或者更好的例子是预训练大语言模型，你知道，聊天机器人的预训练部分，
Let's say you're interviewing at IBM. A recruiter from IBM is reaching out to you and, and they want. to talk to you on the phone, I'll give my tips on, you know, how to go from that initial phone screen and maybe a technical phone screen to an interview that is going to be successful. And then we'll do kind of a similar roundtable. So I see a lot of people who feel like they have, who want to use their agency to get the best possible interview. So here's example. My backgrounds in reinforcement learning, if someone starts asking me about support vector machines or maybe a better example is like pre-training an LLM, you know, the pre-training part of chat
或者这些东西，你知道，我不会是那方面的专家。现在，多年来我成长了，对吧，但如果我刚从大学毕业，带着强化学习学位，有人问我关于监督学习的非常深奥的问题，我不会有像我专门研究监督学习那样的深度。而且我觉得随着时间的推移，你会建立广度。所以我可能倾向于告诉招聘人员：“嘿，不要给我安排监督学习的面试，或者我想做强化学习。”在我看来，这些都是诚实的错误。我明白你的意思，
CBT or these things, you know, I'm not going to be an expert in that. Now, over the years I've grown, right, but definitely if I came out of college with a reinforcement learning degree and I and someone asks me really deep questions about supervised learning I'm not going to have the same depth as if I studied supervised learning right and and I feel like you build breath over time so so I might be inclined to tell the recruiter hey um you know don't give me a supervised learning interview or or I want to do reinforcement learning in my opinion these are all honest mistakes. I see the point,
或者类似的话，比如：“只是提醒一下，我周末不能工作，”或者“只是提醒一下，我必须远程工作，即使办公室就在五英里外。”像这些事情，
or something like, you know, just a heads up, I can't work on the weekends, or just a heads up, I have to work remote, even though the office is five miles away. Like these kind of things,
试图在早期就设定条件，我看来只是人们面试时常见的分类错误。我会解释原因。是的。如果你在另一边，如果你是招聘人员，你有一个试图填补的职位，你正在查看一堆候选人并与招聘经理交谈，你已经总结出：“这就是我在寻找的那种人。”一个很好的例子是，就像你在水滑梯上一样。如果你在水滑梯上，你知道水正顺着滑梯中间冲下来，对吧？如果你去过台风泻湖或任何这些地方，对吧？所以如果你开始滑向滑梯的侧面，
like trying to set yourself up early on, I see as just like a common, common categorical error when people are interviewing. And I'll explain why. Yeah. If you're on the other side of it, if you're a recruiter, you have a you have like a certain position that you're trying to fill and you're looking at a bunch of candidates and talking to the hiring manager you've synthesized down like this is the kind of thing I'm looking for and a good example is like like if you're on a water slide so if you're on a water slide you know the water's like rushing down the middle of the slide right if you ever been to like typhoon lagoon or any of these places right um and so if you ever start sliding up onto the side of
或者像在 F1 赛车中驶入粗糙路面，你的车开始减速，对吧？摩擦力大得多，这根本不是滑流。你想要处于滑梯的中间，招聘人员和你是一致的，招聘经理和你是一致的，你只是在向前飞驰。我看到太多次人们说——这是另一个例子——人们说：“哦，我是数据科学家，所以我可能无法通过编码面试。”像这些事情，提前说出来，我明白你不想参加一场你无法通过的面试。我明白你的意图，但我认为这会造成巨大的损害，因为你最终会陷入无人区，
of the slide or driving in the rough in like formula one your car starts to slow down right there's a lot more friction it's just not slip stream right you want to be in that middle of the slide where the recruiter and you are aligned the hiring manager you're line and you're just flying forward and I see so many times people say here's another one people say like oh I'm a data scientist so like you know I might not pass a coding interview like these kind of things like saying them up front I get it that you don't want to be, you know, you don't want to be in an interview where you can't pass. I get the intent, but I think it does tremendous damage because you end up kind of in no man's land
招聘人员真的不知道该拿你怎么办，或者他们把你转给另一个对你没有内在兴趣的招聘人员，事情就搞砸了。我见过太多次了。百分之百同意。Patrick，随时可以插话，兄弟。是的。不，我的意思是，这是很好的建议。反过来，你也会遇到那些简历注水的人，
where the recruiter doesn't really know what to do with you or they pass you on to another recruiter that isn't organically interested in you and it just falls apart. I've seen it so many times. Agreed 100%. Patrick, feel free to interject, bro. Yeah. No, I mean, this is good advice. I think the reverse, you get people who stuff pad resume,
所以你真的会得到这种分布，有些人撒谎，直接说：“我是机器学习专家。”你问他们，他们说：“嗯，我曾经看过一个 YouTube 视频，我想是 Karpathy 的还是什么的，你知道，我现在对大语言模型了如指掌。”然后你会在另一边遇到这样的人：“嗯，你知道，我不知道。我不确定我是大语言模型方面的专家。我只是把它作为博士学位研究过，并写了一篇卓越的论文。”所以当你面试人们时，这非常奇怪。
so you really get this distribution where some people are lying and just like straight up saying, I'm a machine learning expert. And you ask them and said, well, I watched a YouTube video once from, I think Carpathy or whatever, you know, like, I know all about LLMs now. And then you get people on the other side like, well, you know, I don't know. I'm not sure I'm an expert in LLMs. I only studied it as a PhD and wrote, you know, a preeminent paper in it. And so like you get, when you interview people, it's, it's very strange.
这很难，因为我认为当你坐在桌子的另一边时，你会看到几十、几百个人。所以你试图从中筛选。但这就是信息不对称，它会作为招聘过程的一部分反复出现。教育自己了解这一点，而且，我们之前谈过，确保你意识到这一点，这绝对是一个净收益。
And it's hard because I think when you sit on the other side of the table, you see dozens, hundreds of people. And so you, you kind of try to sift between it. But it's this information asymmetry, which will come up again and again as part of the recruiting process. And educating yourself about it. And, you know, we've talked about before about making sure you're aware of it is really only a net positive.
同样的事情，提出薪资讨论。人们会说：“哦，从第一次面试开始，你就应该说，你能付给我 X 美元吗？”这就像，不，这太糟糕了。不，那不是。你必须意识到，再次回到 Jason 的观点，你交谈的第一个人不是决策者。他们的工作仅仅是把你转给链条上的下一个人，把你横向移动，或者基本上把你从流程中剔除。所以不要撒谎，我不认为那是合适的。但回到 Jason 的观点，我的意思是，只要有足够的自信，不要太多。只要，这听起来很奇怪，要正常。就像，要表现得有吸引力而不夸大其词。你要找到那个中间地带，你有自信，但你也不是在试图说：“听着，我是世界上第三大强化学习专家。所以你最好准备好为这个人付钱。”这就像，哦，奇怪的介绍。
same thing bringing up like salary discussions people like oh from the very first interview you should say well can you pay me X dollars and it's like no this is a horrible like no that is not and you have to realize again at most of these places to Jason's point that first person you're talking to isn't the decision maker it's literally their job to just like either pass you on to the next person in the chain move you sideways or or you know basically dump you out of the process and so don't lie I don't think that's appropriate But to Jason's point, I mean, just like have enough self-confidence, not too much. Just like be, and it sounds really, be normal. Like, just be like appealing without overselling. You're like, find that middle ground where you have confidence, but you're also not, you know, trying to be like, listen, I'm, I'm the number three RL person in the world. So you better be ready to pony up for this guys. It's like, oh, weird introduction there.
或者询问制表符还是空格。我遇到过人们这样做，你知道。第一次和你交谈时，他们问：“你们用制表符吗？我不能在用制表符而不是空格的地方工作。”好的，有趣。你，我会让它过去。继续吧。是的，去做吧。在与公司的初步面试中，我很喜欢这一点，用你的话来说，Jason，就是你从高层让那个人知道：“我只是觉得这个机会超级令人兴奋。”
Or asking tabs of her spaces. I've had people do that, you know. First, first time you talked to. them, oh, do you guys use tabs? I can't work at a place that uses tabs instead of spaces. Okay, interesting. You, I'll let it. Go ahead. Yeah, go for it. Upon an initial interview with the company, I'm a big fan of this, to your words, Jason, is you let that individual know from high level. I just find the opportunity super exciting.
“我洗耳恭听，开始吧。”如你所知，当你与另一个人接触时，当你邀请那个人交谈并控制对话时，这是非常受欢迎的。所以你从那里开始这个过程。但同时，你们俩也都很清楚这一点。你现在已经把自己作为一个听众呈现给那个人了。我们喜欢有听众。最后，我们三个人都能体会到适当插话的巨大乐趣，不是打断，而是插话。
I'm all ears, kick it off. As you know, when you engage with another person, when you invite that person to talk and control the conversation, that's very well received. So you start the process with that. But then also, too, both of you know this well too. You've now presented yourself as an audience to that person. We love having audiences. And then lastly, all three of us can identify with the great joy of proper interjection, not interruption, but interjection.
所以当你倾听对方时，他们为你描绘了蓝图。当他们描绘蓝图时，你可以在最初的介绍中填补那个蓝图。就像，“哇，Jason 和 Patrick，他们懂。他们确切地知道我在说什么。”因为你所做的只是对他们的话发表了一点评论。他们会觉得：“哇，多么高质量的对话。我介绍了机会。他们有很好的想法。”当然，Jason 明确表示他主要是机器学习类型的工程师，而不是强化学习或其他什么，
So as you listen to another party, they paint the landscape for you. And as they paint the landscape, you can fill in that landscape in that initial introduction. Like, wow, Jason and Patrick, they get it. They know exactly what I'm talking about because all you did was just comment a little bit on their words. And they're like, wow, what a quality conversation. I presented the opportunity. They have a good idea. Granted, Jason made it clear he's mostly machine learning type engineer rather than reinforcement learning or this or that.
但他表达得很清楚，哇，他完全理解我在说什么。我想我们应该带他进入下一轮。所以邀请对方，邀请内部招聘人员或招聘经理先发言。他们会描绘蓝图。你将完成那个蓝图。你适当地插话，这会进行得非常好。然后你以说“哇，我超级兴奋。期待下一步。祝你今天愉快”来结束。是的，这很有道理。没有提到薪水，没有提到你的核心专业是什么。只是一个高质量的对话，当你挂断那个虚拟会议时，会让你感觉非常好。是的，这很有道理。
but he made it kind of clear, but wow, he got exactly what I was saying. I think we take him to the next round. So invite the other party, invite the internal recruiter or the hiring manager to speak first. They'll paint the landscape. You'll finish out that landscape. You properly interject, and that goes really well. And then you finish it off by saying, wow, I'm super excited. I'm next steps.
我说，Patrick，当你提到“不要撒谎”时，你触及了一些非常有趣的事情。所以，我认为有两种谎言，可以这么说。有，你知道，
Have a great day. Yeah, that makes sense. No reference to salary, no reference to what your core proficiencies are. just a good quality conversation makes you feel really good when you hang up that virtual meeting. Yeah. That makes a time.
“我是 C++ 专家。”一上来就说。每个人都知道我不是 C++ 专家。我永远不会成为 C++ 专家。那在我的简历上将是一个弥天大谎。
I says, Patrick, you hit on something really interesting when you said, don't lie. So there's, I think there's two kinds of lies, so to speak. There's, you know,
但有些事情，它们还不真实，所以就像，嗯，如果你一心想面试 Android 应用开发人员，也许你做过一点 Kotlin，那么在什么程度上你可以把 Kotlin 写在简历上，并且，你知道，在面试中弄清楚它？你在简历中在多大程度上弯曲现实？我认为这确实是一个公平的观点，我想，听听 Mark 的观点也会很有趣，因为他指导人们如何
I'm an expert in C++. Right off the bat. Everyone knows I'm not an expert to C++. I'm never going to be an expert in C++. That would be a bold-faced lie on my resume.
策划简历。但我认为列出一些东西，比如“嘿，我对这个感兴趣”或者“我熟悉的语言”或者作为关键词，这很酷。我不认为那是撒谎。但如果有人，例如，我需要精通 C++ 的人。所以如果你说，按照你的观点，我是 C++ 的追求者，但不说“追求者”，而我做的第一件事就是把你转给一个会问你 C++ 编码问题的人。然后如果你不会写 C++，那就是一个巨大的失误。现在，如果你说：“嘿，我做过一点 C++，你知道，我很乐意学习它，很乐意用它工作。”
But then there are things where like, they're not true yet so it's like um if if you're if you if you if you have your heart set on interviewing for uh you know an android app developer maybe you've done like a little bit of cotlin it's like at what point can you put cotlin on your resume and and you know kind of you know figure it out through the interviews like how how much do you sort of bend reality in the resume I think that yeah this is a fair point and I guess I would say and and maybe like it would be interesting to to hear Mark's perspective as well like as he sort of coaches people on like how to
“但已经有一段时间了，或者，你知道，我认为在中间地带玩是可以的。”但我的意思是，我以前面试过人，他们说：“哦，我是程序员。我知道这三种语言。”然后你让他们坐下来。我说：“任何语言都可以，没关系，做这个东西。”他们去写一个 for 循环。他们说：“哦，我不记得怎么写 for 循环了。”这就像，等等，什么？“任何语言都可以，它是怎么写的来着？我该怎么算？”这就像，好吧，你不是一个，我不知道你做了什么代码，但你不是一个程序员。所以，当有人被抓到像“哇，这不仅仅是夸大，这简直是直接捏造”时，这真的让人感觉很糟糕。是的，我不，Mark，当你问，当你帮助人们时，我假设，你知道，查看简历或帮助他们策划简历，你给出的关于在正确的沟通水平上放置正确内容的指导是什么？好观点。他们可以在简历上列出这些项目或使其具体化，说明他们的核心语言是什么。他们也熟悉某些东西。我与软件工程师分享的一些话
kind of like curate a resume here but I think it's fine to list things as like you know hey I'm interested or like language I'm familiar with or language and like as keywords cool like I don't think that's lying but then if someone for instance like I need people who are proficient in C++ So if you say, to your point, I'm aspirational in C++, but without saying aspirational, and the very first thing I'm going to do is pass you to someone who's going to ask you a C++ coding question. And then if you can't write C++, like, it's a big miss there. Now, if you say, hey, I, like, I have done a little bit of C++, you know, I'm, you know, happy to learn it, happy to work in it.
是他们的熟练程度是赢得的。他们有幸——我说，嘿，让他们知道这是一种幸运——他们有时被扔进必须立即扩展的环境中，这是不可商量的。他们甚至可以说：“我必须说我最强的语言是 Python。”
But it's been a while or, you know, you know, I think kind of playing that middle ground there is okay. But I mean, I've interviewed people before, like, oh, I'm a programmer. You know, I know these three languages. And you sit them down. And it's like, and I've told them any language you want, it's fine, you know, do this something. And they go to write a four loop. And they're like, oh, I don't remember how to write a four loop. And it's like, wait, what? Like, any language you want, how does it go again? Like, how do I reckon? And it's like, okay, you're not a, like, I don't know what code you did, but you're not a programmer. So I, you, it really leaves a bad taste when someone gets caught in a like, wow, this isn't a stretch.
“但我三年前加入了一家公司，当时我 Python 不太好，但他们向我明确表示。我必须在三到四周内上手，否则他们就得和我谈谈。所以我把这一点说清楚了。”所以，如果你们有一个想给我的项目，有七天的截止日期——因为通常有两种项目，60 分钟的截止日期，他们给你，你打开它，你有 60 分钟。但如果你想给我一些更
This is just a straight up fabrication. Yeah, I don't, Mark, when you ask, when you like help people, I presume like, you know, going through resumes or helping them curate resumes, what kind of guidance do you give about putting the right stuff there at the right level of communication? Good point. They can itemize that or make it specific on their resume, what their core languages are. They're also familiar with something. some words I've shared with software engineers in interviews
详细的、有七天截止日期的项目，是的，我已经 13 个月没碰 TypeScript 了。我可能有点生疏，但我准备好钻研一本书了，并尽我所能。所以你可以向面试官传达，你的整个职业生涯基本上都是由被扔进必须立即上手工作的环境中组成的。你们俩可能都有过那种在你们眼中上手很快的工程师的奢侈。
is that their proficiencies have been earned. They've had the good fortune. I say, hey, let them know it's a good fortune that they've been at times thrown into environments where they've had to scale immediately and it's non-negotiable. And like they could even say, I've got to say my strongest language is Python.
并且到他们可以那样说的程度，他们可以告诉公司他们上手很快。所以再次保持乐观，你知道我的意思吗？而不是向公司确认：“嘿，这些是我最好的语言，这些是第二好的，这些是我有点生疏的。”他们每次被扔进某件事时，总是能扩展。是的，那是很好的建议。继续，Patrick。哦，不，关于撒谎的事情，我会说，不要放你绝对没做过、也没准备好谈论的项目或公司。所以，首先，如果
But I joined a company three and a half years ago where I was not too good in Python, but they made it clear to me. I had to be up and running in three to four weeks or they were going to have to talk to me. And so I made that clear. And so what I'd love to do in terms of a technical assessment, if you had a project that you wanted to give me with a seven-day deadline, because there's often two types of projects, 60-minute deadline, they give it to you, you open it up, you've got 60 minutes. But if you want to give me something a little bit more
你写了一家公司，而你没在那里工作过，或者一个学位，他们大多数时候会做背景调查，它会浮出水面，显示你没在那里工作过。无论你撒谎有多好，你都会——你有时会在新闻中看到，即使是高层人士也会这样做，这对我来说很疯狂。但就像，那是一个直接的，不要越过那条界限。但同时，放项目，比如，如果你放了一个大学的项目或 GitHub 上你做过的东西，然后，你知道，有人问问题，而你没有故事，没有 Mark 所说的叙述。这是一个例子。如果你没准备好谈论，就不要放它。人们放东西上去。然后就像，好吧，我不知道，你为什么把它放在这里？Patrick，是的。那是一个好观点。但过度代表，我们把自己建立得太高，结果却让人失望。谦逊很重要。抱歉，Jason。是的，不，那是一个极好的观点。你知道，有句谚语，比如“万事通，……的专家”。你知道它实际上应该是“万事通，一事精”吗？“万事通，一事无成”是一个笑话，出现在 1800 年代。而那实际上比原版更受欢迎，原版是“万事通，一事精”。所以我认为这就是这里的方法。就像，你知道，如果你知道那家 Android 公司构建 Android 应用需要 Kotlin，也许你没做过很多 Kotlin，你需要成为某方面的专家，对吧？所以你可以说，比如，“我是 C++ 的专家。”
detailed with a seven-day deadline, and yes, I haven't touched tight script in about 13 months. I might be a tad rusty, but I'm ready to dive into a book. and do my best so you can communicate to the interviewer that your entire career has been made up of basically being thrown into environments where you have to get up and running immediately. Both of y'all have probably had the luxury of engineers that have kind of ramped up nicely in your eyes.
详细说明了七天的截止日期，是的，我已经有大约13个月没碰过TypeScript了。我可能有点生疏，但我准备好钻研一本书了，我会尽我所能，这样你就可以告诉面试官，你的整个职业生涯基本上就是被扔进各种环境中，必须立即上手工作。你们俩可能都有幸遇到过在你们看来上手很快的工程师。
And to the point to where they could say that, they could tell a company that they ramp quickly. So just kind of keeping it optimistic again, you know what I mean? Rather than saying to affirm, hey, these are my best languages, these are my second best, and these are the ones I'm kind of rusty with. They always just scale every time
而且他们甚至可以告诉公司他们上手很快。所以还是要保持乐观，你明白我的意思吗？与其去确认说，嘿，这是我最擅长的语言，这是我第二擅长的，而这些是我有点生疏的。他们每次被扔进新项目时，总是能迅速适应。
they're thrown into something. Yeah, that's a great advice. Go ahead, Patrick. Oh, no, on the lying thing, though, I will say, like, don't put, like, projects or companies that you've worked for that you definitely haven't done and you're not ready to talk about. So, first of all, if you put, just as a, like,
是的，这是个很好的建议。请继续，Patrick。哦，不，关于撒谎这件事，我想说的是，不要把你绝对没做过、也没准备好谈论的项目或公司写上去。所以，首先，如果你写了，就像……
if you put down a company and you've not worked there or a degree, like they will most of the time do a background check and it will surface up that you've not been there. And no matter how good you are for lying, you will, and you see it in the news sometimes, even high-level people do this, which is nuts to me. But like, that's a straight-up, like, don't cross that boundary. But then also putting projects down, like, if you put a project down, like from college or a GitHub, you know, thing that you worked on, and then, you know, someone asks questions and you don't have some
如果你写了一家你没工作过的公司或者一个学位，他们大多数时候会进行背景调查，结果会显示你根本没在那里工作过。无论你撒谎的技术有多好，你都会被发现，有时你在新闻里也能看到，甚至高层人士也会这样做，这对我来说简直不可思议。所以，这绝对是不能逾越的界限。但同时，关于写项目，如果你写了一个项目，比如大学里的项目或者GitHub上的东西，然后有人问你问题，而你却没有任何……
narrative, some story to Mark's point. This is an example of this. Like, if you're not ready to talk, don't put it there. People put stuff down. And then it's like, well, I don't, why did you put it here? Like, Patrick, yes. That's a good point. But the overrepresentation, we build ourselves up too much and we disappoint to the downside. Humility matters. Sorry, Jason. Yeah, no, that's a fantastic point. You know, there's that saying, like, Master of All Trades, Jack of...
叙述，没有任何故事，就像Mark说的那样。这就是一个例子。如果你没准备好谈论它，就不要写上去。人们总是把东西写上去，然后面试官问，那你为什么要把它写在这里？Patrick，是的，你说得对。但过度包装，我们把自己吹嘘得太高，结果却让人失望。谦逊很重要。抱歉，Jason。是的，不，那是一个非常好的观点。你知道有句谚语说，万事通，什么都……
Or wait, no, Jack of All Trades, Master of One. Did you know it's actually supposed to be Master of One? Master of None is a joke that came out, like, also in the 1800s. And that actually became more popular than the original, which is Jack of All Trades, Master of One. And so I think that is the approach here. It's like, you know, if you know that Android companies building Android apps need Kotlin, and maybe you haven't done a lot of Kotlin, you need to be a master of something, right? So you can say, like, I am a master of C++.
或者等等，不，应该是“博而不精，一门精”。你知道吗，它原本应该是“一门精”？“样样通，样样松”是一个1800年代出现的笑话。而这实际上比原来的“博而不精，一门精”更受欢迎。所以我认为这才是这里应该采取的方法。就像，如果你知道开发安卓应用的公司需要Kotlin，而你可能没怎么用过Kotlin，你至少得精通某样东西，对吧？所以你可以说，我精通C++。
I know C++ inside and out, but I also, you know, you can put Kotlin as one of your languages. And then, you know, and then if you get. And you should be able to at least write an interview answer in Kotlin, like a four loop, for example. Like that would be pretty egregious, right? But, you know, if push comes to shove, like you can kind of say, hey, you know, my core language is C++, but, you know, I'm learning Kotlin. I've done some things in Kotlin.
我对 C++ 了如指掌，但你也可以把 Kotlin 列为你的语言之一。如果你被问到，你应该至少能用 Kotlin 写出面试题的答案，比如写一个 for 循环。如果完全不会，那确实挺离谱的，对吧？但如果到了紧要关头，你可以说：“嘿，我的核心语言是 C++，但我正在学习 Kotlin，也用它做过一些东西。”
And I would say that that have something you're really good at that is coding software related, right? That's your core. And if you have that, you can. It's much, so in Patrick's example, if someone said, oh, you know, I picked Kotlin because I know, you know, that matters to you, Patrick, but I forgot how to write a four loop. But I know in C++ plus it looks like this, that would be a very different conversation. You'd say, oh, here's the difference. And you could move on from there, right? So, so Jack of all trade is a master of one, I think can help a lot. I do think stretching the truth a little bit is okay. You know, when I was starting out, I put, um, You know, I wrote Kuda kernels from my PhD dissertation to make it run faster. And it was one of these things where, I mean, we didn't have Claude Code, but basically I ran it, I got the wrong answer, I fudged my way through it,
我想说的是，你得有一样真正擅长的、与软件开发相关的技能，那是你的核心。如果你有这个，情况会大不相同。以 Patrick 的例子来说，如果有人说：“哦，我选 Kotlin 是因为我知道这对你很重要，Patrick，但我忘了怎么写 for 循环了，不过我知道在 C++ 里它是这样写的。”那对话的走向就会完全不同。你会说：“哦，区别在这里。”然后继续往下谈。所以，我认为“博而不精不如一技之长”很有道理。我觉得稍微夸大一点点事实是可以接受的。我刚起步时，为了让博士论文的程序跑得更快，我写过 CUDA 内核。当时的情况是，虽然我们没有 Claude Code 这种工具，但我基本上就是运行代码，得到错误结果，然后硬着头皮凑出来的。
and I wouldn't really say that I could write a Kuda kernel efficient. It would be stack overflow and fudging my way through it until I got the answer. But I still put Kuda as one of my, you know, kind of, things that I've done. And so in that sense, I do think that that's kind of where you can kind of play that game. So you don't want to be so humble that you don't put things that are important, but you also don't want to be a liar. You have to find that place where, like, most people would kind of understand where you're
我真的不能说我能高效地编写 CUDA 内核。那完全是靠 Stack Overflow 和硬凑，直到得到正确答案。但我还是把 CUDA 列为我做过的事情之一。从这个意义上说，我觉得这就是你可以玩转的地方。你既不想太谦虚以至于漏掉重要的技能，也不想成为一个骗子。你必须找到那个平衡点，让大多数人能理解你的处境。特别是对于你们两位现在的水平，我得夸夸 Joel，如果一个候选人的简历给人的印象是他们精通 AWS 或某种特定语言，但面试时却达不到你们的标准，那面试就立刻结束了，对吧？没错。
coming from. And especially for both of your levels, I've got to throw some praise at Joel, is that if a candidate candidate's resume gave the impression of both you that they're strong in a WS or particular language but then they didn't meet their bar, your bar, it's over immediately. Right, right.
没错。
I had a situation... I had a situation where someone did ask me a ton of questions. I mean, this is showing my age a little bit, but they asked me a ton of questions about support vector machines, which were popular, you know, in the early 2010s, pre-2010s. And I just didn't know, and I failed that interview. But, you know, what happened was they kind of saw my background.
我遇到过一种情况……有人问了我一堆问题。这有点暴露我的年龄了，但他们问了我一堆关于支持向量机（SVM）的问题，那在 2010 年代初期、2010 年之前很流行。我刚好不知道，那场面试我搞砸了。但你知道吗，他们看到了我的背景。
I kind of got a chance to do another interview on, you know, the area that I did know. And then also, it taught me that there's an area that I don't know. As Support Vector Machines is at least interesting enough that this company was willing to make it a whole interview. And so maybe it is something I should know about. So failing an interview, you know, to wrap this up, like getting the interview and failing it is actually better for you most times than not getting the interview. And so, you know, and so.
我后来有机会参加了另一场面试，面试的是我确实擅长的领域。而且那次经历也让我意识到，有一个我不知道的领域——支持向量机，它至少足够有趣，以至于这家公司愿意专门为此进行一场面试。所以也许这确实是我应该了解的东西。所以，总结一下，参加面试并搞砸它，在大多数情况下其实比根本没得到面试机会要好。所以……
Yes, a learning. It's a learning experience. You nailed it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. As long as you're not like what Patrick says, very egregious. If you haven't mastered one skill in the field,
是的，这是一种学习经历。你说得太对了。只要不像 Patrick 说的那么离谱就行。如果你在这一行里连一项技能都没掌握，
you have to go and do that first and then come back and listen to this episode. Okay, so you landed the interview. We talked a little bit about this, but what are some tips to passing the interview? Obviously, you have to know your technical stuff, but, you know, going beyond that, what are some, or maybe, you know, like, what are some general tips that any SWI can use to pass an interview? you want to start mark kick us off i'll kick it off um there is value especially for both of you whatever the answer might be in volume in the time that you deliver that answer and to the point everything that you're just looking for in the answer sometimes when we are asked questions we go
那你得先去补课，然后再回来听这一集。好了，你拿到了面试机会。我们之前聊过一点，但通过面试有什么技巧吗？显然，你必须精通技术，但除此之外，或者说，有什么通用的技巧是任何软件工程师都可以用来通过面试的吗？你想先开始吗，Mark？我来开个头。无论答案是什么，在回答时控制好节奏和时长是非常有价值的，特别是对你们两位来说。有时候我们被问到问题时，会
on narratives that extend well beyond what that person was even looking for and that will immediately test y'all's patients too in addition to missing it so you go okay also okay in terms of the Patrick, this is what you're, okay, all right, this is what you're looking for, specifically type script. Okay, here we go. And then they start delivering that answer, and it would be nothing more than what you asked for. So, and again, starting originally how you invite, both of you get invited to kick off the process, you drive the whole process, you drive the direction of the interview, and then your answers are specifically what you asked of. This day and age, the majority of people, their answers aren't enough or they're too much. Ouch.
滔滔不绝，讲的内容远远超出了对方想听的范围，这不仅会让你错过重点，还会考验面试官的耐心。所以你要说：“好的，明白了。Patrick，这是你想要的，好的，没问题，这就是你想要的，具体是 TypeScript。好的，开始。”然后他们开始回答，内容不多不少，正好是你问的。再说一次，从你们最初受邀开始，你们就要掌控整个过程，引导面试的方向，并且回答要精准。在这个时代，大多数人的回答要么不够，要么太多。哎哟。
Yeah. That's a great point. If I were on a job search for both of you, our phone calls wouldn't even last three minutes. I'm sometimes on calls that are eight and a half minutes long and my eyes are just glazed over, you know, because it was more than we needed. Yeah. That's a great point. A lot of people don't give the interviewer time to talk. And one thing to recognize, well, there's actually two things I'll talk about. One is interviewing is a very, very insecure. It will challenge your security and your confidence. And the reason is the interviewer has asked that question a hundred times and has the answer right there in front of them. You don't. You've never seen this question before. And so that can feel really intimidating. I've had
是的，说得好。如果我是你们的招聘方，我们的通话甚至持续不了三分钟。我有时参加的电话面试长达八分半钟，我听得都走神了，因为内容超出了我们的需求。是的，说得好。很多人不给面试官说话的机会。有一点要认识到，其实有两点。第一，面试是一个非常、非常让人缺乏安全感的过程。它会挑战你的安全感和自信心。原因在于面试官已经问过这个问题一百次了，答案就在他们面前。而你没有。你以前从未见过这个问题。所以这会让人感到非常畏惧。我经历过
interviews where like I actually did really well and thought I did terrible because it felt like the interviewers were always one step ahead. And I just didn't take into account. the fact that well yeah they know the answer already right um and so your interviewer knows the answer and if you um if you show that you know your general stuff and you engage in a two-way dialogue sometimes you can actually get hints uh that that you know you wouldn't have got otherwise yeah i think the a couple of things also to your point jason sometimes the person asking the question can be missing an assumption intentionally or unintentionally or just be straight up wrong.
一些面试，我表现得其实很好，但觉得自己表现得很糟糕，因为感觉面试官总是领先我一步。我只是没考虑到这样一个事实：他们已经知道答案了。所以，你的面试官知道答案，如果你表现出你精通基础知识，并进行双向对话，有时你甚至能得到一些提示，否则你是得不到的。是的，我也觉得，Jason，回到你的观点，有时提问的人可能会有意或无意地遗漏一个假设，或者干脆就是错的。
Like, oh, you're, and as a person being interviewed, you have to handle that very carefully. Like, you can say, you know, hey, there's an issue here. Or I'm not sure I understand or I don't agree. Or can we, can we like, like, can I do it this way? Or sort of, and to your point, if you're gracious about it, the person will kind of just tell you what they're looking for. and you think that's a black mark, but if you handle it with grace,
比如，“哦，你是……”作为被面试者，你必须非常小心地处理这种情况。你可以说：“嘿，这里有个问题。或者我不确定我是否理解，或者我不同意。或者我们可以……我可以这样做吗？”或者类似的话。而且，正如你所说，如果你表现得体，对方会直接告诉你他们想要什么。你可能觉得这是一个扣分项，但如果你处理得体，
it's much better than if you become, which I've had before, they become very inflamed and combative. But I also think that a lot of people who conduct interviews are themselves, which is very unfortunate, insecure. So they're trying to prove by virtue of having picked a challenging question that has some trick to it,
这比变得愤怒和好斗要好得多，我以前见过这种情况。但我还认为，很多进行面试的人本身（这很不幸）缺乏安全感。所以他们试图通过挑选一个带有陷阱的难题来证明自己知道自己在做什么。
that they know what they're doing. And there are a lot of bad interviewers out there, but their managers also somewhat know that. And so the feedback from those interviews is taken based on the person doing the interview. But coming back to something that Mark said like a lot earlier and I think makes sense here. And this is like one of those like it's actually just general life advice, I guess. But people like talking. So the more that you can give a succinct answer and let the interviewer talk, the more positive
有很多糟糕的面试官，但他们的经理也多少知道这一点。所以这些面试的反馈是基于面试官本人的水平来评估的。但回到 Mark 很早之前说的一点，我觉得在这里很有道理。这其实就是一种生活建议：人们喜欢说话。所以，你给出的答案越简洁，让面试官多说话，他们对这次谈话的感觉就越积极，
they feel about the conversation because when they reflect back on it, they're left with this experience of like, I like that guy, you know? And it's like, no, you're just like yourself. but we all like ourselves or you don't have massive issues. So, I mean, I think that's like a very, very real part of it. And the way to get there in my mind, I think mentally can be realizing that, like, you are good enough to, like, apply for this job. They wanted to talk to you.
因为当他们回想起来时，他们会留下一种“我喜欢那个人”的体验。这就像是，不，你只是喜欢你自己而已。但我们都喜欢自己，除非你有严重的心理问题。所以，我认为这是非常真实的一部分。在我看来，达到这一点的心理建设是意识到：你足够优秀，可以申请这份工作。他们想和你谈谈。
They want to ultimately hire you. So they want to have time to pitch you. So in every one of those interviews, yes, they're like grading you. But if you're a good candidate, you should feel like you're a good candidate. you should feel like you're a good candidate to have a little bit of that confidence. Maybe you have to do that thing in the mirror where you make yourself big and roar or whatever.
他们最终是想雇佣你的。所以他们想花时间向你推销公司。因此，在每一场面试中，是的，他们在评估你。但如果你是一个优秀的候选人，你应该感觉自己很优秀。你应该感觉自己是一个优秀的候选人，要有一点自信。也许你得做那种对着镜子把自己撑大、咆哮之类的动作。
I don't know one of those techniques. But then you should realize that the reason they're talking is because they want to pitch you. They want to convince you. I think a lot of candidates get this belief that like, oh my gosh, I would be so desperately lucky to work here. And I guess maybe that gets into dating advice or something, which I have also not done in a very long time.
我不知道那种技巧。但你应该意识到，他们之所以说话，是因为他们想推销自己。他们想说服你。我认为很多候选人都有这种信念：“天哪，如果能在这里工作，我真是太幸运了。”我想这可能涉及到约会建议之类的，我也很久没做过那种事了。
But you don't want to be desperate. Like let them pitch you. let them sell you. Now, don't ask them like, well, why should I work here? Okay, you got to be subtle about it. But there's a, there's a craft there. And it takes a maturity to answer not too short, not too long. And like, and that comes with growth. And everything you talked about, Patrick, it's the hidden emotion underneath is that individual's curious. We love curious individuals. They just want to know, wow, what is Jason and Patrick doing? I find it super cool. I'm all ears and I'm just going to give you what you ask of me and nothing more, you know,
但你不想表现得绝望。让他们来推销你。让他们来吸引你。现在，不要问他们：“好吧，我为什么要在这里工作？”好吧，你得委婉一点。但这是一种技巧。这需要成熟度来回答，不能太短，也不能太长。这随着成长而来。Patrick，你谈到的一切，隐藏在下面的情感是那个人很好奇。我们喜欢好奇的人。他们只是想知道：“哇，Jason 和 Patrick 在做什么？”我觉得这太酷了。我洗耳恭听，我只会给你你要求的，不多不少，你知道，
the answer. Yeah, I think, you know, because interviews are like, you know, artificially demoralizing for the things we talked about, you have to kind of, I love your example, but I imagine Patrick in the mirror like, oh, I'm a lion. You have to be artificially moralizing to really cancel that out. You know, I think, you know, I remember I had a, a, uh, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, interview where, you know, this is becoming less of an issue nowadays, but, but this was a big issue before, well, one, before I really knew about the other areas of AI, and two, when
答案。是的，我认为，因为面试在某种程度上是人为地让人士气低落的，正如我们所谈到的，你必须……我喜欢你的例子，但我能想象 Patrick 在镜子前说：“哦，我是一头狮子。”你必须人为地提升士气来抵消那种感觉。你知道，我记得我曾有过一场面试，这在今天已经不是什么大问题了，但在以前是个大问题。第一，在我真正了解 AI 的其他领域之前；第二，当
reinforced and learning was not really, really known or popular. And, and I got asked all these kind of tough questions. And then I should remember, like, in between that and the next interview, you know, and you should do this no matter how your interview went. In between, if you have a bunch of interviews back to back. Take a moment in between and just like, you know, just remember that like, you're awesome. Like, just say to yourself, like, I'm an awesome. I'm great. I deserve love. You know, I'm good enough. And then go into that next interview. And I think, you know, having optimism is is maybe the number one thing, you know, being optimistic. I think like every job that I've left, well, there's been like a couple of jobs I've left because the next
强化学习还不为人知或不流行的时候。我被问到了一堆难题。我应该记住，在那场面试和下一场面试之间（无论你面试表现如何，都应该这样做），如果你连续有几场面试，中间休息一下，提醒自己：你很棒。对自己说：“我很棒。我很优秀。我值得被爱。我足够好。”然后进入下一场面试。我认为保持乐观可能是第一重要的事。我想我离开的每一份工作，好吧，有几份工作是因为下一个
opportunity was way better. And so I kind of like left on a high note and sort of, you know, used that high note as an investment, right? But, but every other job I've left, and this is, you know, tracks, you know, broadly, you know, people leave, the number one reason people leave is they don't like their manager, right? The number two reason people leave is they don't like their company, right? This is the data, right? And so you're going to leave on a low note, statistically, right? At least some percent of the time, you're going to leave on a low note. And so if you're already coming in on a low note,
机会好得多。所以我算是高调离职，并把那种高调当作一种投资，对吧？但其他我离开的每一份工作（这在统计上很普遍），人们离职的第一原因是他们不喜欢他们的经理，对吧？第二原因是他们不喜欢他们的公司，对吧？这就是数据。所以你很可能会在低谷时离职，从统计学上讲，至少有一定比例的情况是这样。所以如果你已经带着低落的情绪入职，
then you're like a flight risk before you've even started, right? So, so like you need to show them that like, yeah, you really care, you're interested in this, and that you have sort of a long runway at this company. You're going to be at this company four or five, six years. You know, that I think is something that comes through with, with sort of curiosity and with optimism. And you can kind of feel these things.
那你还没开始就成了“飞行风险”，对吧？所以你需要向他们展示你真的很在乎，你对这份工作很感兴趣，并且你在公司有很长的职业规划。你打算在这家公司待四、五年、六年。我认为这是一种通过好奇心和乐观精神体现出来的东西。你可以感受到这些。
So kind of projecting that has a huge impact, even if it might not seem that way. Beautiful. And your words also spoke to surprising to the upside, Jason, aren't interviews. They just come away, very happy with the interview. It went well, and they surprised to the upside. Again, Jason, I've got to drop praise on you, bro.
所以投射出这种感觉会有巨大的影响，即使看起来不像那样。太美了。你的话也说到了意外的惊喜，Jason，面试不就是这样吗？他们离开时对面试非常满意。进展顺利，而且他们感到惊喜。再说一次，Jason，我得夸夸你，兄弟。
You're special. You're freaking special. But what's amazing at the time that you were coming out of University of Central Florida, you maybe had a little bit in the back of your mind, oh, damn, what are they going to think of me compared if I'd gone to University of Florida or Georgia Institute of Technology? I went to Florida State. I went to Florida State at a time when you couldn't get into University of Florida. You went to Florida State. That's where all the dumbest went. So that's where I went to school. But I always had perceptions about what
你很特别。你真是太特别了。但令人惊奇的是，当你从佛罗里达中央大学毕业时，你脑子里可能有一点点想法：“哦，该死，如果我去了佛罗里达大学或佐治亚理工学院，他们会怎么看我？”我去了佛罗里达州立大学。我去佛罗里达州立大学的时候，那是你进不去佛罗里达大学才去的地方。你去了佛罗里达州立大学。那是所有笨蛋去的地方。所以我去了那所学校。但我总是对别人如何看待
other people thought of programs, then they interview you and you knock the damn thing out of the park. Right. Yeah, I think having that optimism. Yeah, definitely. yeah definitely okay what else Patrick Mark what other thoughts about passing the interview a nice close out so it's a nice conversation
其他学校有偏见，然后他们面试你，你把那件事做得非常出色。没错。是的，我认为保持乐观。是的，绝对的。好的，还有什么？Patrick，Mark，关于通过面试还有什么想法？一个很好的收尾，这是一次很好的谈话。
hey Jason Patrick I really enjoyed my time there's an awesome conversation if the next step is a technical assessment or some code assignment throw it at me I'm all game I just really enjoyed our conversation and thank you so much you shared a lot of details
嘿，Jason，Patrick，我真的很享受这段时间，这是一次很棒的谈话。如果下一步是技术评估或代码作业，尽管发给我，我准备好了。我真的很享受我们的谈话，非常感谢。你分享了很多关于
about the opportunity I'll stand by on my end and again this was after you allowed Them to kick off the interview, you properly interjected after they painted the landscape, a good quality conversation, and you let them know that you're still, and no questions about salary, no questions about coming into the office, we saved that for the offer stage. This was just an awesome conversation. I'm looking forward to next steps.
这个机会的细节。我会等你们的消息。再说一次，这是在你允许他们开启面试，在他们描绘了蓝图后你适当地插话，进行了一次高质量的谈话，并且你让他们知道你仍然……没有关于薪水的问题，没有关于进办公室的问题，我们把这些留到发 Offer 阶段。这只是一次很棒的谈话。我期待着下一步。
Let me know what you need me to do. Hey, have a great day. Take care, guys. See you later. Bam, nice and positive ending. Yeah. That is great. Okay, another kind of thing that I'm thinking about, and this is brand,
让我知道你需要我做什么。嘿，祝你们有愉快的一天。保重，伙计们。回头见。砰，一个积极的结尾。是的，太棒了。好的，我还在想另一件事，这是我最近
new in my mind as I've been interviewing people for circuit I kind of feel like in today's day and age you should ask for an on-site interview I kind of feel like you know if if the interview is done online I think both parties aren't really getting enough of the right kinds of information to the point where you know if if God forbid like circuits you know falls over and we run our money and I have to go look for a job. I feel like I'm going to demand, and we just talked about not doing this, so I'm going against what we really said.
在面试 Circuit 的人时想到的。我觉得在当今时代，你应该要求进行现场面试。我觉得如果面试是在线完成的，双方似乎都没有得到足够的信息。以至于如果，天哪，如果 Circuit 倒闭了，我们的钱花光了，我不得不去找工作。我觉得我会要求……我们刚才谈过不要这样做，所以我违背了我们刚才说的话。
But I feel like I'm really going to push hard for an on-site interview, even if that means I have to fly somewhere versus doing it all on the internet. Mark, Patrick, what's your takes? Go ahead, Patrick, I'm all ears, bro. Yeah, I mean, on my opinion, I could see there's value there.
但我感觉我真的会极力争取现场面试，即使这意味着我必须飞到某个地方，而不是在网上完成所有事情。Mark，Patrick，你们怎么看？来吧，Patrick，我洗耳恭听，兄弟。是的，我的意见是，我能看到其中的价值。
And I think this, again, we should be mildly careful. When I came out of college, the idea of flying somewhere to do an interview when I was more or less a very low amount of money would have been very onerous. And so I think we have to take that into consideration. But if you're further along in your career where the reality of like hotel and flight for a couple days is is really not a big deal in the grand scheme of things, if you can offer that, if like you said, pushing for it, I think I'm fine. with but I mean depending on the company you're interviewing with if it's a large conglomerate
而且我认为，再次强调，我们应该稍微小心一点。我刚出大学时，如果我没什么钱，还要飞到某个地方去面试，那会非常沉重。所以我认为我们必须考虑到这一点。但如果你在职业生涯中走得更远，酒店和机票的费用在宏观层面上真的不是什么大问题，如果你能提供这一点，就像你说的，极力争取，我觉得没问题。但取决于你面试的公司，如果是一家大型企业
or whatever like they might just have a policy and so they may not be set up to host you on site so just be aware that like you can say oh hey is there an option to do an on-site interview and I think that could be fine but you'd have to know your audience a bit I guess because yeah I mean I agree 100% on that I mean I think there is definitely upside to it if you are willing to accept it or offer to do it even even if it's at your own cost, I think you're right. There's probably an enormous, you know, initiative that you're showing by doing that. So that alone could be like definitely pay dividends. And another neat thing is that as we well know, there is still a pretty material delta between
或者其他什么，他们可能有政策，所以他们可能没有准备好让你现场面试。所以要注意，你可以说：“哦，嘿，有没有现场面试的选项？”我觉得这没问题，但你得了解你的听众。因为是的，我 100% 同意这一点。我的意思是，如果你愿意接受或主动提出这样做，即使是自费，我认为这绝对是有好处的。你表现出的主动性本身就可能带来巨大的回报。另一件巧妙的事情是，正如我们所知，
virtual meetings and in person. So you could reference, hey, I've really enjoyed the process from here. And if you need me to fly out just to meet everyone in person, I'd love to. And then this is special. if your consistency results in a very positive in-person interview after two to three positive virtual interviews, you basically kind of slam dunked that process. I mean, we already know if the three of us got together for coffee, it'd be a damn good time. Patrick, Jason and I got together.
虚拟会议和面对面会议之间仍然存在巨大的差距。所以你可以提到：“嘿，我很享受目前的流程。如果你需要我飞过去和大家面对面交流，我很乐意。”然后这很特别。如果你的表现始终如一，在两到三次积极的虚拟面试后，进行一次积极的面对面面试，你基本上就锁定了胜局。我的意思是，我们都知道，如果我们三个人聚在一起喝咖啡，那会是一段非常美好的时光。Patrick，Jason 和我聚在一起。
We had a hell of a time. I even felt like I don't even belong in your presence, but we still had a damn good time. It was awesome. It was awesome. So point being, you can say that you are hungry and you'd love to try to come out, oh, my travel schedule is kind of rough
我们玩得很开心。我甚至觉得我不配出现在你们面前，但我们仍然玩得很开心。太棒了。太棒了。所以重点是，你可以说你很渴望，很乐意尝试过去，哦，我的旅行计划有点紧
for the next couple weeks, but I'd love to meet everyone in person. And then when you have that positive in-person experience that's consistent with the positive virtual experiences, bam, slam dunk. Yeah, that makes sense. So I guess to kind of like reconcile all this,
接下来的几周，但我很乐意和大家面对面交流。然后当你有了那种与积极的虚拟体验一致的积极的面对面体验时，砰，大功告成。是的，这说得通。所以我想，为了调和所有这些，
yeah, definitely, you know, don't say, oh, if the interview is remote, I'm not interested. Like, definitely you don't want to set ultimatums like that. Good point. But I think it's good to, say, hey, is it possible or, you know, given the choice, I'd love to do the interview on site.
是的，绝对，你知道，不要说：“哦，如果面试是远程的，我不感兴趣。”绝对不要设定那样的最后通牒。说得好。但我认为说“嘿，有没有可能”或者“如果有选择的话，我很乐意现场面试”是很好的。
And, you know, I actually, I actually interviewed at a place where I was, I was, you know, in the middle of getting my PhD. I didn't end up taking it. I finished the doctorate program, but they actually had this system where you could book the flight in the hotel and they reimbursed you because they figured, oh, PhD students are all broke, which is totally right. And so most companies, you know, now we have, this is all pre-Zo. I'm talking about 2007 or something. But, you know, so companies have the option to interview remote, and that's definitely cheaper for them.
而且，我实际上曾在一家公司面试过，当时我正在攻读博士学位。我最终没有去。我完成了博士课程，但他们确实有一个系统，你可以预订机票和酒店，他们会报销，因为他们想：“哦，博士生都没钱。”这是完全正确的。所以大多数公司，你知道，现在我们有……这是在 Zoom 之前。我说的是 2007 年左右。但，你知道，所以公司可以选择远程面试，这对他们来说肯定更便宜。
But, you know, you can always float that. And if you can float it where they pay for it, that's the best. I would highly recommend taking them up on that and doing the interview in person. If you're going to spend four, five, six, eight, 20 years at a company, it's probably worth it to fly over there and meet the people before you pick which one that is. So even if you have to pay out of pocket,
但，你知道，你总是可以提出来。如果你能让他们买单，那是最好的。我强烈建议接受他们的提议并进行面对面面试。如果你要在一家公司待四、五、六、八、二十年，飞过去见见人，在选择之前确认一下，这可能是值得的。所以即使你必须自掏腰包，
I think if you're really serious about a company, then I would probably make that flight. And in fairness, the company probably, if it gets to that point, the company probably would pay. Yeah, I mean, it's a relatively small amount of money. I mean, there's some logistics around
我认为如果你真的对一家公司很认真，那么我可能会选择那次飞行。公平地说，如果到了那个地步，公司很可能会买单。是的，我的意思是，这是一笔相对较小的钱。我的意思是，有一些物流方面的问题，
how do you pay a flight for someone who's not an employee. So they have some logistical things, but yeah, they should, from a financial standpoint, should totally do it. All right, so you pass the interview. Now, this next step is
比如如何为非员工支付机票。所以他们有一些物流方面的问题，但是的，从财务角度来看，他们完全应该这样做。好了，你通过了面试。现在，下一步是
really interesting because sometimes it's not even a thing that you can even do. And other times, it's the most important thing. And this is the reverse interview. So if you interview at a big company, one of several things will happen. Either they will basically tell you, look, you have to accept the offer and then we're going to place you wherever we think you belong. That can happen. That happened to me at Google. I ended up writing
非常有趣的，因为有时这甚至不是你能做的事情。而其他时候，这是最重要的事情。这就是反向面试。所以如果你在大公司面试，会发生几件事之一。要么他们基本上会告诉你：“看，你必须接受 Offer，然后我们会把你安排在我们认为你属于的地方。”这可能会发生。我在谷歌就遇到过这种情况。我最终写了
JavaScript for a year and it actually was fine. And so in that case, I didn't have a reverse interview. I took whatever job they suggested for me. Um, but, uh, you know, as you get more senior or as you interview at smaller companies or, or whatever, you can have the opportunity to do a reverse interview. So this is where, you know, you might have an offer or you might just have a verbal offer. Um, but the company has said, you passed. You know, your interview went great. Um, and you get an opportunity to meet your boss, uh, talk to the rest of the team. maybe talk to the executives, right? So, Mark, I'd love to hear from you because you have such a diverse set of folks that you've helped. What is the kind of reverse interview process like in general? And how do you sort of coach people through that? What I often say when we get to that stage is let them know, again,
一年的 JavaScript，其实还不错。所以在那次情况下，我没有进行反向面试。我接受了他们为我建议的任何工作。嗯，但是，你知道，随着你变得更资深，或者你在较小的公司面试，或者其他什么，你就有机会进行反向面试。所以这就是你可能已经有了 Offer，或者只是口头 Offer 的地方。但是公司已经说：“你通过了。”你知道，你的面试进行得很棒。而且你有机会见到你的老板，和团队的其他成员交谈，也许和高管交谈，对吧？所以，Mark，我很想听听你的意见，因为你帮助过各种各样的人。总的来说，反向面试过程是什么样的？你是如何指导人们完成这个过程的？我经常说，当我们到达那个阶段时，让他们知道，再说一次，
you're super excited to meet with your hiring manager. and if you don't mind me asking hiring manager, just what my core function will be, what you'll need out of me, the primary requirements, ramp up time, it's usually over three months or something like that. But whatever you need for me, I can start prepping now just so I walk into this ready to go. As we well know, the number one thing for all new employees at a company is to get up and running as quickly as possible with the team. So what do you need on my end? What do you need me to do? Again, my constant theme is the sense of service. So even though we've made it past the interview stage, it does make an argument, okay, well, what are you going to pay me? What are my benefits look like? We can politely do that stuff. But you're my boss. What do you need me to do? Nothing is more better received than the sense of service to another person. And so when the boss feels that, he or she will drop those requirements, what needs to be done, what they need to have done in the first 30, 60, 90 days. Okay, awesome. Thank you.
你非常兴奋能见到你的招聘经理。如果你不介意我问的话，招聘经理，我的核心职能是什么，你需要我做什么，主要要求是什么，入职时间，通常是三个月左右。但无论你需要我做什么，我现在就可以开始准备，这样我进去时就准备好了。正如我们所知，所有新员工在公司的第一要务就是尽快与团队一起上手。所以你需要我做什么？你需要我做什么？再说一次，我一贯的主题是服务意识。所以即使我们已经通过了面试阶段，这确实提出了一个论点：“好吧，你打算付我多少钱？我的福利是什么样的？”我们可以礼貌地谈论这些事情。但你是我的老板。你需要我做什么？没有什么比对他人的服务意识更受欢迎的了。所以当老板感受到这一点时，他或她会列出那些要求，需要做什么，他们需要在前 30、60、90 天内完成什么。好的，太棒了。谢谢。
I'm on it. Hey, I might talk with HR. I haven't had a chance to look at the health care benefits. I don't take much vacation, but I'm going to check into PTO. And then something else, the itemized if then, we'll talk about that when it comes to negotiating salary, is that, oh, God, I know they came in at 170. if you can do 180, I'll open up that docky sign, fill out all the fields, and set my start date. When you set definitive actions, if a company can do something, there's candidates today. If you can do 180, yeah, I feel a little bit better about it.
我这就去办。嘿，我可能会和 HR 谈谈。我还没机会看医疗福利。我不怎么休假，但我会去查一下带薪假。还有别的事，如果……我们谈到协商薪水时会谈到这一点，就是：“哦，天哪，我知道他们给的是 17 万。如果你能给 18 万，我会打开那个 DocuSign，填好所有字段，并设定我的入职日期。”当你设定明确的行动时，如果一家公司能做点什么，现在的候选人是这样的：“如果你能给 18 万，是的，我感觉好一点。”
Shit, I'm not going to give you 180 then. But when you do a defined, you know, anything that you ask of your manager to give to you that you will do, including signing the offer, flying out in person, it's well received. So you can say to that hiring manager, hey, what do you need out of me
该死，那我就不给你 18 万了。但当你做出明确的……你知道，任何你要求经理提供给你的、你将要做的事情，包括签署 Offer，亲自飞过去，都会受到欢迎。所以你可以对那个招聘经理说：“嘿，你前 30、60、90 天需要我做什么？”我会现在就开始学习。再说一次，这会非常受欢迎。是的，这说得通。我认为反向面试是一个难得的机会，让你有机会见到某个人，
these first 30, 60, 90 days? And I'll start studying now. And again, it will just be so well received. Yeah, that makes sense. I think the reverse interview is a rare opportunity for you to potentially meet somebody
他……我不知道该怎么说。例如，我在 LinkedIn 进行了一次反向面试。我最终没有接受 Offer，我去了别的地方，但是
who is, I don't know how to say this. so for example I did a reverse interview with LinkedIn I end up not taking the offer I end up going somewhere else but
我见到了 Deepak Argoal，他在 AI 领域非常出名，几年后我在一个晚宴活动上又见到了他。但反向面试有时你会见到一些人，你知道，至少
but I met Deepak Argoal who's super famous in the AI world and I actually met him again years later at kind of a dinner event but but the reverse interview sometimes you meet people who you know at least
像那些可能不在你圈子里的人。这是一个非常好的机会，可以真正了解那个人。所以你会得到一些很好的机会来了解人们是如何思考的，他们是如何说话的，他们是如何看待公司的，以及他们是如何看待自己的工作风格的，并对未来有一个一瞥。然后当你和你的招聘经理交谈时，我认为最重要的事情是试着想象你自己
like who might not be in the circles that you're in And that's a really good opportunity to really learn a lot about that person. So you'll get some great opportunities to learn how people think, how they talk, how they think about the company and how they think about their working style and get sort of like a glimpse into the future. And then when you talk to your hiring manager, I think the biggest thing is try to imagine yourself.
一直和这个人交谈。这是你真的想每周花几个小时在一起的人吗？我认为这很重要。你知道，我见过人们接受了工作，你知道，在非常知名的公司获得了惊人的薪酬待遇，但所谓的“蜜月期”很快就过去了。归根结底，在蜜月期结束后，是你和你的直接团队，特别是你的经理，每天大部分时间都在交谈，而你其余时间都在写代码。如果你是初级员工，你可能说话少，写代码多，
talking to this person all the time. You know, is this someone that you really want to spend hours and hours a week with? I think that's important. You know, I've seen people take jobs, you know, that were given amazing compensation packages at very reputable companies, but the sort of honeymoon phase, you know, wears off quickly. And at the end of the day, like, after the honeymoon phase is over, it's you and your immediate team, especially your manager, talking to each other, you know, for a huge portion of the day and you writing code for the rest of it. And if you're junior, you might do less talking and more
这有时还挺好的。但你仍然会和这群核心人员进行大量的交谈。最终这并不重要，你知道，当你在和人们一起工作了一年、两年、三年后，公司是在做骨头还是网站，或者公司是一家律师事务所，这几乎不重要，你最终会形成一种社区，那变成了你的生活。如果那真的很不开心，会让你非常不开心。没有别的东西能真正填补那个空白。太棒了，Jason。再说一次，你们两个都达到了你们现在的水平，不仅是因为你们的才华，还因为你们对那些人的交付。我想在你们早年的时候，
coding, which, you know, it's kind of nice sometimes. But you will still do a lot of talking with this core group of people. And it doesn't matter ultimately, you know, like at some point when you've been working with people for, you know, a year, two years, three years, it almost doesn't matter whether the company is making bones or a website or if the company is a law office, like you just end up forming sort of this community and that becomes your life. And if that is really unhappy, it makes you very unhappy. Nothing else can really fill that void. Love it, Jason. And again, both of you got to levels that you did, not only with your brilliance, but your delivery for those people. I imagine earlier in your years,
你们是观众中安静的成员之类的，你们只是做了摆在面前的任何事情，随着时间的推移，这提升了你们。有些人使用言语和阴谋手段，他们可以提升自己，如果你非常聪明，但你也有很强的自我，你知道，你可以在生活中做得很好，但你们两个都是通过服务意识成功的，你们交付了摆在面前的一切，你们可能都有非常好的谦逊，然后它促成了与那些人的非常高质量的谈话，然后你们在 30 岁之前就和那群人在一起了，你们和他们是平等的。是的，是的，完全是。所以，让我们想想，让我们想象你有几个 Offer，正如我们所说，人们离职的第一原因
you guys were some of the quiet members of audiences and whatnot and you just did whatever was put in front of you and that elevated you over time some people use words and conniving efforts and they can elevate themselves if you're very intelligent but you're also got a hell of an ego on you and you know you can do well in life but both of you guys made it through your sense of service you delivered on everything that was put in front of you you probably both had very nice humility about you and then you it contributed to just very good quality conversations with those people and then you were damn both of you before age 30 you were up and with that crowd you were a peer level with them yeah yeah totally so so the let's think let's imagine you have several offers and as we said the the number one reason people leave their jobs
是他们的招聘经理。招聘经理显然非常重要。候选人在反向面试中可以做些什么来发现危险信号？我先抛出一个。是的。嗯，好的，我想确保我匿名化。我删除了这个故事中的 PII，个人信息。但我进行了一次反向面试，嗯，招聘经理花了很多时间谈论他们
they're hiring manager hiring manager is obviously very important what are things that a candidate can do in that reverse interview, like to find red flags. I'll throw one out there. Yeah. Um, uh, okay, I want to make sure I anonymize. I get rid of the PII, the personal information out of this story. But I, I did a reverse interview and, um, and the hiring manager spent a lot of time talking about how, um, they had a much higher position at their last company and how, you know, They took a lower position at this company and they were trying to spin it as kind of a, like, I'm going to be fast-tracked because I was super high up at the last company. But they were also like really bemoaning it. And I could tell that there was real insecurity there.
在上一家公司职位高得多，以及他们是如何在这家公司担任较低职位的，他们试图将其描述为一种……就像，“我会因为我在上一家公司职位很高而被快速提拔。”但他们也真的在抱怨。我能看出那里有真正的不安全感。
And I could tell that this is somebody who's going to climb to the top and probably step on my face on the way there and use my face to get, you know, to get. get to the next rung of the ladder. Yeah. And so I think insecurity is actually the number one red flag. If your manager is insecure and if they spend a lot of time talking about their own personal growth, you know, in the future, that is a, that is, you know, if you have the choice, you should run away from that. A great 100%. Patrick, feel free to run with that. Yeah. What are other red flags, Patrick?
我能看出这是一个会爬到顶端，并可能在途中踩在我的脸上，利用我的脸到达梯子下一级的人。是的。所以我认为不安全感实际上是第一大危险信号。如果你的经理缺乏安全感，如果他们花很多时间谈论他们自己未来的个人成长，你知道，如果你有选择，你应该远离那个。太棒了，100%。Patrick，请随意继续。是的。还有什么其他危险信号，Patrick？
yeah i mean i'm not sure about red flags but i guess for me and and we kind of pivoted weirdly but but it kind of doesn't it is like thinking about career growth right like you know you mentioned like hey you can what you call like fail upward there are people who for some reason seem really bad at their job but just came to like get promoted they always leave right before everything goes to you know flames and you know it's bad like uh but and you got to be careful when you're kind of picking a manager but i think if if i think back through my career and this is what i try So like when people ask me, you know, for this kind of advice is think through like, what kind of mentorship are you looking for? And are you getting that mentorship like from your
是的，我的意思是，我不确定危险信号是什么，但对我来说，我们以奇怪的方式转换了话题，但这确实就像是在思考职业成长，对吧？就像你提到的，你可以“向上失败”。有些人因为某种原因看起来工作真的很糟糕，但只是为了得到晋升，他们总是在一切化为灰烬之前离开，你知道，这很糟糕。但你必须小心，当你选择经理时。但我认为，如果我回顾我的职业生涯，这就是我尝试做的。所以当人们问我这种建议时，就是思考一下：你在寻找什么样的指导？你是否从你的
manager or from the team or from your position or are you not looking? I'm just looking to practice my craft and I'm looking to drive in a more leadership role. And I think there's a being real about what it is that you are looking for. It sounds kind of bad like out of the job. Well, of course, a paycheck. Like that's true. But then also there's a big difference working for a deeply technical manager versus a person who's expecting you to be independent and autonomous. And we talked about how you represent your resume, but you also need to understand what they're looking for. And Mark kind of mentioned that. Like, how do I, like, what is the next step here? What are you looking for me to do? How are you looking for me to ramp up?
经理、团队或职位那里得到了那种指导？还是你没在找？我只是想磨练我的手艺，我想在领导角色中更有作为。我认为对你正在寻找的东西保持真实是很重要的。这听起来有点糟糕，就像“为了工作”。好吧，当然，为了薪水。那是真的。但除此之外，为一位深度技术型的经理工作和为一位期望你独立和自主的人工作有很大的不同。我们谈到了你如何展示你的简历，但你也需要了解他们在寻找什么。Mark 提到了这一点。比如，“我该怎么做？这里的下一步是什么？你希望我做什么？你希望我如何上手？”
Is a key indication of making sure you understand the thing? Because getting the job is great, but in practice, what matters more is like the area under the curve. Well, unless maybe you're getting a $100 million signing bonus, then maybe that impulse is all that matters. But like in general, like getting a good momentum can cover up for a lot of other issues and you can really accelerate if the manager is saying, look, I'm looking for people to come in
这是确保你理解这件事的关键指标。因为得到工作很棒，但在实践中，更重要的是曲线下的面积。好吧，除非你拿到 1 亿美元的签约奖金，那么也许那种冲动才是最重要的。但总的来说，获得良好的动力可以掩盖许多其他问题，如果经理说：“看，我正在寻找人们加入……”你真的可以加速。
and like churn and work with me and they have a history of execution, then, you know, you can learn that. If they're coming in and saying, look, I'm looking for you to come in and start delivering for sort of technically leading the work, a team, whatever. you need to say, like, am I going to be able to do that or is there going to be a missed expectation there? And I think those initial things are really, really important and understanding
如果他们有执行力，并且愿意与我共事，那么你知道，这些是可以习得的。如果他们加入时说，看，我希望你进来后能开始交付成果，或者在技术上领导某项工作、某个团队等等，你需要问自己：我能做到吗？还是说这会造成期望落差？我认为这些最初的事情非常非常重要，而且要理解
what your and your manager's relationship expectation is going to look like. And so having a wrong one there, I guess there's a really long-winded way of saying, like a red flag is a misalignment there. If you are really junior in something, and there's overlap, right? You can you can realize that it always is going to feel really hard or too much burden. And so it's not saying that you have to feel like I can come in and crush it. Like that's not always true. Like you can grow into it. But if there's too big of a delta there, then you can run into trouble. Excellent point. Yeah. Totally agree. Oh, there. You're back. Okay. He faded out for a bit. So one other thing I noticed in I really dislike.
你和经理之间的关系期望会是什么样子。所以，如果这里出现了偏差——我想这是一种很啰嗦的说法——红旗信号就是这种不匹配。如果你在某方面非常资浅，而工作内容又有重叠，对吧？你会意识到这总是会让人感觉非常困难或负担过重。所以，这并不是说你必须感觉自己能进来就大杀四方。那并不总是事实。你可以通过成长来胜任。但如果其中的差距太大，你就会遇到麻烦。说得太对了。是的，完全同意。哦，你回来了。刚才你的声音淡出了一会儿。那么，我注意到的另一件事，我真的很不喜欢。
this has become almost like a political thing. So take this word literally, not figuratively. Really look for diversity on the team. Like you want, you know, a group of people who have a variety of different skill sets and interests and people who are dynamic. And, you know, you want something that is, you know, like people who are ultimately culture builders if the team are all kind of people who have known each other since high school
这几乎变成了一件政治化的事情。所以，请字面理解这个词，而不是比喻。真正去寻找团队的多样性。你想要的是一群拥有各种不同技能和兴趣、充满活力的人。而且，你知道，你想要的是那些最终能成为文化建设者的人。如果团队里的人都是从高中起就认识的，
and you don't know them like if you're in the group that's fine but if the team is all people who knew each other since high school except you that I think is going to be very difficult so you know and it's also a sign like how did that team end up that way I mean, it's not very organic, right?
而你又不认识他们——如果你在那个群体里那还好，但如果团队里除了你之外所有人都是高中同学，那我认为会非常困难。所以，你知道，这也是一个信号：那个团队是怎么变成那样的？我的意思是，这看起来不太自然，对吧？
So one thing I look for is, I do look for, you know, people who come from a variety of different backgrounds and we're still kind of able to come together, that there is kind of like a process for growing this team that really attracts, you know, people who have, you know, who have a certain passion and regardless of kind of how they got there. So that's one thing I kind of look for. And there is diversity in that dynamic, Jason. As you can imagine, we all want to support diverse cultural and backgrounds and everything like that. But that whole movement got a little off track a couple of years ago and whatnot. Right. It's, yeah, you find the diversity in the way an individual thinks and the way they break down problems. And you can feel that through three or four interviews that this person would contribute. to the company's culture.
所以我寻找的一件事是，我确实在寻找那些来自不同背景的人，并且我们仍然能够以某种方式走到一起。团队成长过程中有一种流程，能够真正吸引那些拥有某种热情的人，无论他们是如何走到这一步的。所以这是我寻找的一点。这种动态中存在多样性，杰森。你可以想象，我们都想支持多元的文化和背景等等。但整个运动在几年前有点偏离了轨道之类的。对吧？是的，你会在一个人的思维方式和他们拆解问题的方式中发现多样性。通过三四轮面试，你就能感觉到这个人是否会为公司文化做出贡献。
Yeah. Yeah, definitely. Okay, so we've done the reverse interview. We have one, maybe more companies that, where there's mutual, you know, we both like each other, you know, you like the job, the job likes you. So now we get to the offer phase. I'll throw out a few things just to kick off this discussion, and then maybe we'll go Mark and then Patrick and we'll go around the table.
是的，绝对是。好的，我们已经完成了反向面试。我们有一家，也许更多家公司，双方都有意向，你知道，我们彼此喜欢，你喜欢这份工作，这份工作也喜欢你。现在我们进入报价阶段。我会先抛出几点来开启讨论，然后也许我们让马克和帕特里克也谈谈，我们轮流发言。
A few things, you know, I... I think that, you know, you should try not to make the first offer unless you're looking for exactly what you already have. That's kind of the exception. So if you have a compensation of X and you're looking for exactly X, you could throw that out there. If you get kind of pressured to reveal your compensation, what I usually say is something like, you know, I think that compensation data is pretty confidential. And, you know, I don't really feel it's fair to my current employer to tell you all of the details that they have taken so much time and energy preparing for me, right? And so try to not give out the first offer. With that said, you also want to be super in tune to what your expectations. is. And there's levels. FYI. There's a bunch of resources for this. But I think the way to do this is beforehand, you know, before you really take the job or start even negotiating, think about, like,
有几件事，你知道，我认为你不应该主动提出第一个报价，除非你正在寻找的正是你已经拥有的东西。那算是一种例外。所以，如果你的薪酬是X，而你正在寻找的正是X，你可以提出来。如果你被迫透露你的薪酬，我通常会说类似这样的话：我认为薪酬数据是相当保密的。而且，我觉得告诉你们现任雇主花费了这么多时间和精力为我准备的所有细节，对我来说不太公平，对吧？所以尽量不要给出第一个报价。话虽如此，你也要非常清楚自己的期望。顺便说一下，这有等级之分。关于这一点有很多资源。但我认为最好的做法是事先，也就是在你真正接受工作甚至开始谈判之前，思考一下：
what is the bare minimum that you would take for this job? And, you know, it might even be zero. Maybe you're working for FEMA doing some disaster relief for the flooding we're having here in Texas, and you would do it for free, right? Now, should you do it for free? Maybe not. not, but at least like you set that lower bound. Maybe the lower bound is, I need to make more than I'm making right now. Otherwise, it's just not going to happen because I'm paycheck to paycheck, right? Like, maybe that's your lower bound, right? But set that lower bound in advance because the more you talk to the company, the more invested you are, you know, emotionally and literally in your time, and the more you're likely to compromise. And so setting something in advance, right? And then on the other
你接受这份工作的最低底线是什么？而且，它甚至可能是零。也许你正在为联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）工作，处理我们德克萨斯州这里发生的洪水灾害，你会免费去做，对吧？现在，你应该免费做吗？也许不应该，但至少你设定了那个下限。也许下限是，我需要赚得比现在多。否则这根本不可能发生，因为我是月光族，对吧？也许那是你的底线，对吧？但要提前设定那个底线，因为你和公司谈得越多，你在情感上和时间上投入就越多，你就越有可能妥协。所以要提前设定好。而在另一方面，
side, and Mark, you kind of alluded to this, set your upper bound. Set the number that if they reach that number, you're gone. You're gone. I mean, take two weeks notice, but like, you're, you're effectively gone today. Like, you sign the offer today that you'll start a month from now or whatever it is, but you're gone. So set those two limits in advance. That, I think, is so important. This day and age, job descriptions, the vast majority of them have the salary range on there. so in that introductory conversation that comes up and hey that salary range works perfectly for me and everything and again it's just all about creating that very positive experience in that first round then doing well technically that's the beautiful thing software engineering professions a lot like
马克，你刚才提到了这一点，设定你的上限。设定一个数字，如果他们达到了这个数字，你就走人。你走定了。我的意思是，提前两周通知，但你实际上今天就走了。你今天签了报价，一个月后开始工作或者其他什么，但你已经走了。所以要提前设定这两个限制。我认为这非常重要。在这个时代，绝大多数职位描述上都有薪资范围。所以在那个介绍性的谈话中，如果谈到了，嘿，那个薪资范围对我来说非常完美，等等。同样，这一切都是为了在第一轮中创造那种非常积极的体验，然后技术上表现出色。这就是软件工程职业的美妙之处，很像
athletics you've got to deliver on that technical assessment you've got to show that technical horsepower and then if you do the in-person final onsite and everything again to your point jason you almost start interviewing the company, the pivot changes from you pursuing the company, the company is now starting to pursue you. And you can have that private conversation. Now, if the job tops at 170, you can't throw 205 out there. That's out. But you could say, hey, I am currently at 163K base. I've got about an 8% bonus. And they do match my 401k. That takes me up to about 181. I just wanted to ask, Jason, if a buck 80's on the table on the base, again, I'll open up that document and I'll sign. I'm ready. Right. Right. And then the beautiful
体育竞技，你必须在技术评估中交付成果，你必须展示那种技术实力。然后，如果你完成了面对面的最终现场面试，再次回到你的观点，杰森，你几乎开始面试公司了。重心从你追求公司，变成了公司现在开始追求你。你可以进行那次私下的谈话。现在，如果这份工作的上限是17万，你不能抛出20.5万。那是不可能的。但你可以说，嘿，我目前的底薪是16.3万美元。我还有大约8%的奖金。他们还匹配我的401k。这让我总收入达到大约18.1万。我只是想问，杰森，如果底薪能给到18万，我马上打开文件签字。我准备好了。对。对。然后美妙的
thing is, if you decline that offer, but y'all come back with 176, I still won. I got your company's best offer. I got the best offer. Yep. Yep. I think that, you know, having that weight behind it of you know you give me this offer yeah and in exchange i'm giving you a guarantee signature that is really how you negotiate um and then if they come back with um you know something less than that then what that means is you have to decide whether you should lower your upper bound or not and that takes time this this is another thing that is actually in hot debate so you know, do you, what do you do with an exploding offer? My view historically has been to basically ask for more time.
事情是，如果你拒绝了那个报价，但你们回来给出了17.6万，我还是赢了。我得到了你们公司最好的报价。我得到了最好的报价。是的。是的。我认为，拥有那种支持，即你给我这个报价，作为交换，我给你一个保证签字，这才是你如何谈判的方式。然后如果他们回来给出的东西比那个少，那就意味着你必须决定是否应该降低你的上限，这需要时间。这是另一个实际上在激烈争论的话题，所以，你知道，你如何处理一个即将过期的报价（exploding offer）？我过去的做法基本上是要求更多时间。
But I think that the way you really counter, the proper way to counter an exploding offer is with your upper bound. Like, because you've set that upper bound in advance, you're totally prepared to handle exploding offers. If someone says, oh, I didn't explain it. exploding offers where someone says we're offering you this but you have to sign in the next 24 hours if they come back with that you just come back with your upper bound you said hey you know i've already thought this through and actually i need this and if you give me this then i'll sign it in the next hour
但我认为，真正反击即将过期报价的正确方式是使用你的上限。因为你已经提前设定了上限，你完全准备好处理这种报价。如果有人说，哦，我没解释清楚。即将过期的报价是指有人说我们给你这个报价，但你必须在接下来的24小时内签字。如果他们那样回来，你只需用你的上限反击。你说，嘿，我已经考虑过了，实际上我需要这个，如果你给我这个，我会在接下来的一个小时内签字，
in the next five minutes because like you've already kind of like dealt internalize the exploding offer and so you can see well you know the fact that you're not offering me this is why i can't sign in the next 24 hours. So you're kind of putting, you know, the responsibility and the agency back on them. And you can do that when earlier in the process, you have let them know that the problem space the company is in makes you very curious. You find it very interesting. And you really like your hiring manager. It's not talk about it enough in tech, but one of the greatest luxuries is just having a great boss that you love working for and they drop stuff on your table and you knock it out. Those two dynamics. Interesting work. You really,
在接下来的五分钟内，因为你已经处理并内化了那个即将过期的报价。所以你可以看出，你没有给我这个报价，这就是为什么我不能在接下来的24小时内签字。所以你是在把责任和主动权交还给他们。当你在流程早期让他们知道公司所处的领域让你感到非常好奇、非常有趣，并且你真的很喜欢你的招聘经理时，你可以这样做。科技行业对此谈论得不够，但最大的奢侈之一就是拥有一位你热爱为其工作的好老板，他们把任务交给你，你就出色地完成它。这两种动态。有趣的工作。你真的，
like the boss that you're going to have. So yeah, if you guys can do these numbers, I'm ready to sign. Yeah. Patrick, what are your thoughts negotiating the offer? Yeah, I guess there, so taking it back to stuff, most people aren't aware for tech offers that it isn't just a salary. So, you know, people outside of tech won't realize it if you're a new hire. Maybe it's with levels FYI, I feel like, well, first of all, it's a little weird sometimes. It can be non-reflecting. So be careful. And same thing for, you know, glass store or anything. Like just be careful because it's a, there is a bias in people either up or down on
喜欢你将要拥有的老板。所以是的，如果你们能做到这些数字，我准备好签字了。是的。帕特里克，你对谈判报价有什么看法？是的，我想，回到刚才的话题，大多数人不知道科技行业的报价不仅仅是薪水。所以，你知道，科技行业之外的人不会意识到这一点，如果你是新员工。也许是通过Levels FYI，我觉得，首先，它有时有点奇怪。它可能无法反映真实情况。所以要小心。对于Glassdoor或其他任何东西也是一样。只是要小心，因为人们在报告时存在向上或向下的偏差。
on who report. But the offers that tech companies are typically composed of many pieces, a signing bonus, which is what we were joking about hearing for the AI people with meta. But then also there can be relocation money that can be part of the package. There can be a base salary. There can be options or RSUs. If it's a public company, there can be. a private company, sorry, a startup, you know, an equivalent thing. But then also, Mark
但科技公司的报价通常由许多部分组成，签约奖金，也就是我们开玩笑说Meta给AI人才的那种。但也会有搬迁费，这可以是方案的一部分。会有底薪。会有期权或限制性股票单位（RSUs）。如果是上市公司，会有。如果是私营公司，抱歉，初创公司，你知道，类似的东西。但还有，马克
was mentioning a bonus that's a target that can adjust. So it's really like the total package can be complicated. And there may be certain things. Like you'll hear advice on the internet like, oh, negotiate for more vacation. It's like, well, that's an option you can ask about, but just realize some companies may not have that as a lever. They may not be able to do that. Oh, that's an informational thing. Great point, Patrick. That would simply be, hey, do you have your vacation. Yeah. And so I think getting those things on the table too because 401k match is money at the end of the day and taking a job with either like, hey, you're at a really high PTO relative to this company and you're going to be a new hire. And even if you're pretty senior,
提到的奖金，那是一个可以调整的目标。所以总方案确实可能很复杂。而且可能有一些特定的东西。比如你会听到网上的建议说，哦，去谈更多的假期。这就像，嗯，这是一个你可以询问的选项，但要意识到有些公司可能没有这个杠杆。他们可能无法做到这一点。哦，那是一个信息点。好观点，帕特里克。那仅仅是，嘿，你们有假期吗。是的。所以我认为把这些事情摆到桌面上也很重要，因为401k匹配归根结底也是钱。接受一份工作，比如，嘿，你相对于这家公司有很高的带薪休假（PTO），而你将是一名新员工。即使你资历很深，
a new hire may have very limited days off. That's like, and there's a cash equivalence there. Like, you know, you would pay money to get time off. Right. And so you got to kind of like roll those things up into it a bit. But I agree mostly with what everyone is saying. I will also just say like things not written down like in the actual offer letter aren't worth anything. Oh, I'm going to get you this, but you're going to be up for a promotion. I am going to get your promotion within a year or two. Oh, totally. Like no, that's not like that that doesn't cut it. Like it's go for the offer, you know, sort of as written. That being said, again, there can be games played with a vesting schedule. So I'm going to give you X amount of stock over four years, but it's,
新员工可能只有非常有限的休假天数。这就像，而且这有现金等价物。就像，你知道，你会花钱去换取休假时间。对。所以你必须把这些东西稍微整合进去。但我基本同意大家所说的。我还要说的是，没有写在实际报价信里的东西一文不值。哦，我会给你这个，但你会有晋升机会。我会在一两年内给你晋升。哦，完全是。不，那不行，那根本不算数。去争取书面上的报价。话虽如此，再次强调，归属时间表（vesting schedule）可能会玩花样。所以我要在四年内给你X数量的股票，但它是，
vesting, backloaded. You're only going to get 10% in the first year. So if you don't stick around, and you've got to be really weary, like, that might be policy, but there might be a really bad churn. So famously, one of the big tech companies had a really bad churn problem. And so they would backload RSUs because people would leave after year one or year two. And so they could lure people in, burn through them, and then they would leave of their own accord. And so just, I guess, informationally, be aware online of what people are saying.
归属，后端加重（backloaded）。第一年你只能拿到10%。所以如果你不留下来，你必须非常警惕，这可能是政策，但也可能是一个非常糟糕的人员流失问题。所以众所周知，一家大型科技公司有非常严重的人员流失问题。所以他们会把RSUs后端加重，因为人们会在第一年或第二年后离开。这样他们就可以诱骗人们进来，榨干他们，然后他们就会自愿离开。所以，我想，从信息角度来看，要注意网上人们在说什么。
think through your own story about what what you are wanting. If there's relocation involves, you got to be honest with yourself and your family about that. Like, are you really going to move to this place for that amount of money? What is what is really the cost of living going to be for you? So like, you know, talk about like Texas versus Bay Area, people like, oh, Bay Area, real estate's really, really expensive. But the question is, what about for you?
思考一下你自己的故事，关于你想要什么。如果涉及搬迁，你必须对自己和家人诚实。比如，你真的会为了那笔钱搬到那个地方吗？对你来说，生活成本到底会是多少？所以，比如，谈论德克萨斯州和湾区，人们会说，哦，湾区，房地产真的非常非常贵。但问题是，对你来说呢？
Are you, can you make it work for you? Can you like make the opportunity balance out? And so I think that comes in a bit too, and it's really complicated. And that often can be discovered, believe it or not, Patrick, even after the second or third interview, that's something that would make the company feel pretty well, that in terms of relocating, you've already talked it over with the family. Yeah, the cost of living, you've already measured that. You've already looked at some real estate. A lot of those, that would make the company feel good, at least, that you've already researched all that, potentially. Yeah, yeah, that's true.
你能让它为你所用吗？你能让机会平衡吗？所以我认为这也有点关系，而且真的很复杂。信不信由你，帕特里克，这通常甚至在第二或第三次面试后就能发现，这会让公司感觉相当不错，关于搬迁，你已经和家人商量过了。是的，生活成本，你已经衡量过了。你已经看过一些房地产了。很多这些，至少会让公司感觉良好，你已经研究了所有这些，潜在地。是的，是的，那是真的。
And just as like a side note, often, by the time you get to them making you an offer, it is so hard to get candidates through at most good companies to that point. Don't abuse it, but you don't have to like have low confidence either. So getting them to a specific number may or may not be slow or difficult, but in general, they don't want to walk away at that point. And there are companies, Jason probably is the same thing. If you make it through the interview process, you go into a database and they will pest you for the rest of your life because like they need.
顺便提一下，通常情况下，当你让他们给你报价时，在大多数好公司里，让候选人走到那一步是非常困难的。不要滥用它，但你也不必表现得信心不足。所以让他们达到一个特定的数字可能会也可能不会很慢或很困难，但总的来说，他们不想在那一刻放弃。而且有些公司，杰森可能也是一样。如果你通过了面试流程，你进入了一个数据库，他们会纠缠你一辈子，因为他们需要。
know that you're you can pass the interview and so they will keep sending you like would you be interested again would you be interested again so don't feel like it's it's as much pressure as they want to kind of make you feel to to to hurry up and make a decision and so hey i need my family to check out the area is there a possibility to give me time or you know whatever they may offer to fly you and your family out to the place to check it out these are all things that like become on the table that aren't strictly just like a dollar and sense you know kind of kind of what happens but yeah absolutely knowing how much but it's really hard because it can be literally all over the table you could be vastly underpaid you could be being
知道你能够通过面试，所以他们会一直给你发信息，比如你还会感兴趣吗？你还会感兴趣吗？所以不要觉得这像他们想让你感觉的那样有压力，要赶快做出决定。所以，嘿，我需要我的家人去看看那个地区，有没有可能给我时间，或者你知道，无论什么，他们可能会主动提出让你和你的家人飞到那个地方去看看。这些都是可以摆到桌面上的事情，不仅仅是金钱和意义上的那种，你知道，发生了什么，但绝对是的，知道多少钱，但这真的很难，因为它可能完全在桌面上。你可能被严重低估了，你可能被
vastly like overpaid so it's really hard to say people say don't leave for anything less than 20 percent yeah but those absolutes are are such a struggle they are and then because most of us end up with so much stock-based compensation the underlying company makes up a huge portion the difference between, you know, Google stock, Apple stock, Facebook stock and a startup or, you know, something else. Cisco or something.
严重高估了。所以很难说，人们说不要为了低于20%的涨幅而离开。是的，但那些绝对值真的很难处理。它们确实是，而且因为我们大多数人最终都有大量的股票薪酬，基础公司占据了很大一部分。你知道，谷歌股票、苹果股票、Facebook股票和初创公司，或者其他什么。思科或其他什么。
Yeah, or Cisco. Like those relative momentum, velocity, value, future stock expectations, like it becomes, it can dominate over, you know, a 5% difference. And I think Mark was pointing out, like, or Jason,
是的，或者思科。那些相对动量、速度、价值、未来股票预期，它变得，它可以主导5%的差异。而且我认为马克指出了，或者杰森，
like you're picking your boss, right? If you can find a boss that you really like and that you think you could deliver for and would stick up for you, you got to think about the iterative, amount of that too. Like, what about five years down the road? 10 years? Like, are they going to help you grow your network? Like, those all things have intrinsic value too. It could. You can make an
你是在选择你的老板，对吧？如果你能找到一个你真正喜欢的老板，你认为你能为他交付成果并且他会为你挺身而出，你也必须考虑迭代的价值。比如，五年后呢？十年后呢？他们会帮助你扩展人脉吗？这些东西也都有内在价值。它可以。你可以提出一个
argument almost amounts to anything. I mean, Patrick, look at freaking Jason. And if we found a 23-year-old graduate with the machine learning background and they were a little hustler from Texas A&M, and they got an opportunity to work for Jason, I would take that even if, you know, Goldman Sachs. is offering 45K more a year in annual compensation, but your boss is up in New York City and you look disconnected. No way. You take the offer with Jason. Yeah, I think
论点，几乎可以等同于任何东西。我的意思是，帕特里克，看看杰森。如果我们找到了一个23岁的毕业生，有机器学习背景，而且他们是来自德克萨斯农工大学的小拼命三郎，他们有机会为杰森工作，即使高盛提供每年多4.5万美元的薪酬，但你的老板在纽约市，你看起来很脱节。没门。你会接受杰森的报价。是的，我认为
that done deal. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. Patrick, I mean, just to double click on something you said, you never, ever, ever accept future rewards. Like, it is not a good idea. These things like, oh, you'll get promoted in the future, or I'm going to put you on some fast track. I've seen people get
那是一笔成交的交易。是的，这非常有道理。帕特里克，我的意思是，为了深入探讨你所说的一点，你永远、永远、永远不要接受未来的奖励。这绝对不是一个好主意。这些事情，比如，哦，你将来会得到晋升，或者我要把你放在什么快车道上。我见过人们被那个
burned by that so many times. So here's what's going to happen. You will, you will end up maybe on a, let's say the best case scenario, you'll end up on some kind of fast track. But, you know, because you didn't get the offer you really wanted, you just got the promise in the future of the offer you wanted. That's going to make you insecure. And because you're insecure, you're going to be the worst hiring manager because we've talked about in the past. So like, you can't, you can't do that. It's a trap. I've seen people fall. into it. And so now, now there's a flip side. I think on one side, you know, um, you should, you should look yourself in the mirror after the interview and tell you love yourself and that you deserve
烧伤过很多次。所以会发生什么呢？你最终可能会，假设最好的情况，你最终会进入某种快车道。但是，你知道，因为你没有得到你真正想要的报价，你只是得到了未来你想要的报价的承诺。这会让你感到不安全。因为你不安全，你会成为最糟糕的招聘经理，因为我们过去谈过。所以，你不能，你不能那样做。这是一个陷阱。我见过人们掉进去了。所以现在，现在有一个反面。我认为一方面，你知道，你应该在面试后照照镜子，告诉自己你爱自己，你值得
love. You're great. On the flip side, on the flip side, um, you know, you, everybody dies, right? Everybody dies. And, and nobody's going to care a hundred years from now that your last job was VP of engineering or just software engineering like nobody the end of the day like you can't get hung up on the past i see people who especially in management you know manager jobs are getting decimated and you might have had some really lofty title and and you might say well i want to hold on to this title and the respect and the the uh the org chart power that it comes with all of that but you know things change so fast. Like when Patrick and I were starting our careers,
爱。你很棒。在另一方面，在另一方面，你知道，每个人都会死，对吧？每个人都会死。一百年后，没人会关心你上一份工作是工程副总裁还是仅仅是软件工程师。没人关心。归根结底，你不能纠结于过去。我看到人们，特别是在管理层，你知道，经理职位正在被摧毁，你可能曾经拥有一些非常崇高的头衔，你可能会说，好吧，我想保持这个头衔和尊重，以及它带来的组织架构权力，所有这些。但你知道，事情变化太快了。当帕特里克和我开始我们的职业生涯时，
just being able to code was huge leverage, you know? And now, you know, it's less of leverage. Like there's a lot more people who can code. It's becoming even more prevalent, like friends of mine who have never coded in their life now with AI tools are starting to code. And the reality is the leverage of just being a pure coder, unless you're a good architect,
仅仅能够编码就是巨大的杠杆，你知道吗？而现在，你知道，它的杠杆作用变小了。有更多的人能够编码。它变得越来越普遍，比如我那些从未编码过的朋友，现在有了AI工具，也开始编码了。现实是，仅仅作为一名纯编码员的杠杆作用，除非你是一名优秀的架构师，
that leverage is going down. And the leverage of being a good manager, frankly, is going down. And so you might have to take a title cut. You might have to take a pay cut to make you happy if you're not happy in your current job. That's just a reality. And Jason, you'll love this dynamic. To these poor souls, I have worked with some senior director and VPs of engineering. And immediately upon the search, they say, Mark,
那种杠杆作用正在下降。坦率地说，作为一名优秀经理的杠杆作用也在下降。所以你可能不得不接受头衔降级。如果你在当前工作中不快乐，你可能不得不接受减薪来让自己快乐。这只是一个现实。杰森，你会喜欢这种动态。对于这些可怜的灵魂，我曾与一些高级总监和工程副总裁共事过。搜索一开始，他们就说，马克，
I don't want to take a cut in title. I don't want to take a cut in pay. Nine months goes by. I'm not hired. They haven't found a job. But here's very disappointing. Then they're ready to make the concession. They're even ready to go down to a manager.
我不想降低头衔。我不想减薪。九个月过去了。我没有被录用。他们没有找到工作。但这里非常令人失望。然后他们准备做出让步。他们甚至准备降级到经理。
But that mindset, holding that for nine months, they've kind of deteriorated. And they don't even qualify to be a manager anymore. Yeah. You know, me, when we hold onto a status that we can't achieve anymore, we hollow out. We're no longer at that, you know. There's these senior partners at law firms that are in their 60s. They still pound their chest and everything. They know all the principles, but they haven't done the nitty, gritty details in years.
但那种心态，保持了九个月，他们已经有点退化了。他们甚至不再具备担任经理的资格了。是的。你知道，当我们坚持我们无法再达到的地位时，我们就会被掏空。我们不再处于那个，你知道。律师事务所里有这些60多岁的资深合伙人。他们仍然拍着胸脯等等。他们知道所有的原则，但他们多年来没有做过具体的细节工作了。
So you dig into them a little bit and they fall down. That's what's happening with some VPs out there. I'll try to feel for them. Yeah. I mean, I think in general, there's this thing, and maybe this hits, you know, when you get to a certain point in your career, but this, like, monotonic, ever in you know, pay title, like that's a bit of a, like very, very few people industries that also change jobs like we do in tech would have that. And a lot of times, if you were, you know,
所以你稍微挖掘一下他们，他们就倒下了。这就是一些副总裁正在发生的事情。我会试着同情他们。是的。我的意思是，我认为总的来说，有这样一件事，也许当你达到职业生涯的某个点时会遇到，但这种单调的、永远在薪水、头衔上的增长，这有点，非常非常少的人，像我们在科技行业那样换工作的行业会有这种情况。很多时候，如果你是，你知道，
take a nurse or whatever, there's like very standardized pay and you may move up, you may negotiate, but there isn't this like, oh, every year you're, you know, moving up and up and up and up and up, sort of almost without bound. It's a, it's a very unique, unique thing. But then to Mark's point to, I'll say, sometimes you have to realize the thing that you're doing is gaining expertise in a very, very particular managing team, whatever, and that the chance of having the next opportunity be a strict up or up and diagonal move is goes really down. So as an individual contributor, it may be pretty straightforward. If you're a manager or a manager of manager or above, of, it's very difficult to find a new rule
做一名护士或其他什么，有非常标准化的薪水，你可能会晋升，你可能会谈判，但没有这种，哦，每年你都在，你知道，不断地向上、向上、向上、向上，几乎没有上限。这是一个非常独特的、独特的事情。但回到马克的一点，我会说，有时你必须意识到你正在做的事情是在管理团队等方面获得非常、非常具体的专业知识，而下一次机会是严格向上或向上且对角线移动的可能性真的降低了。所以作为个人贡献者，这可能相当直接。如果你是经理或经理的经理或以上，很难找到一个新角色
where you can just plug in to an existing team at that level versus rise to that level. And so being realistic about that is very important. Yeah. Yeah, totally. Beautiful. Beautiful. And again, that's a nice luxury that both you have.
在那里你可以直接插入到现有团队中，而不是上升到那个水平。所以对此保持现实是非常重要的。是的。是的，完全正确。太美了。太美了。而且再次强调，这是你们俩都拥有的一个很好的奢侈。
I've got to toss it a little bit. You guys are at, not saying you guys can even go higher, right? Celebrity status might be like the next step or, you know, but no, y'all are. I have a podcast, man. Come on. I need more Twitter followers for them. Yeah, you're at the top end. I'll start following you on Twitter, Jason.
我得稍微抛开一下。你们处于，不是说你们不能更高，对吧？名人地位可能是下一步，或者，你知道，但不，你们是。我有一个播客，伙计。拜托。我需要更多的推特粉丝。是的，你们处于顶端。我会开始在推特上关注你，杰森。
Oh, we'll have a lot of fun. But both of you are at the upper, upper ends of your ladder, and you had the luxury of just being able to stay there. Yeah. Yeah, I think that over time, you know, in the same way as, like, the job changes and leverage for jobs change over time. you also change over time as a person. And so sometimes you might outgrow a job
哦，我们会玩得很开心。但你们俩都处于你们阶梯的最顶端，你们有奢侈的条件可以留在那里。是的。是的，我认为随着时间的推移，你知道，就像工作变化和工作杠杆随时间变化一样。你作为一个人的时间也在变化。所以有时你可能会超越一份工作，
or sometimes it might just your priorities change. And so when you're negotiating, one thing that they're going to ask you, especially when you, oh, let me explain a little bit. So the way you negotiate an offer or what actually happens on the other side of the table is there's a finance, talent development kind of department that that figures out the bands which means the lowest and the highest compensation a person can make at a certain level.
或者有时可能只是你的优先级改变了。所以当你谈判时，他们会问你的一件事，特别是当你，哦，让我解释一下。所以你谈判报价的方式，或者在谈判桌另一边实际发生的事情是，有一个财务、人才发展部门，他们计算出薪资带，这意味着一个人在某个级别可以获得的最低和最高薪酬。
They figure out those bands and then they also look at your resume and they have a bunch of ways of deciding what your offer should be. And so then when you ask for more, what's going to happen is the recruiter you're talking to, they want you to make infinite money because they want to close the deal and it's not their money, right? Yeah. So you're not really negotiating with the recruiter, although they represent the people you are negotiating with, but you're not talking directly to them. So trying to be persuasive and stuff like that is not really that useful.
他们计算出这些薪资带，然后他们也会看你的简历，他们有很多方法来决定你的报价应该是什么。所以当你要求更多时，会发生的是，你正在交谈的招聘人员，他们希望你赚无限的钱，因为他们想达成交易，而且那不是他们的钱，对吧？是的。所以你并不是真的在和招聘人员谈判，尽管他们代表了你正在谈判的人，但你不是直接和他们谈。所以试图表现得有说服力之类的并不是很有用。
what's going to happen is they are going to take your request to the next level up. And so if you're within band, then a director, maybe even a manager or a senior manager could just approve it. Once you go outside of the band, it can actually still get approved, but it has to require higher and higher levels, right? So, you know, if you have Mark Zuckerberg approval, you could get $100 million offer. is clearly out of the band. So at some point you can get infinite offer, but think of it as
会发生的是，他们会把你的请求带到更高一级。所以如果你在薪资带内，那么总监，甚至可能是经理或高级经理就可以批准它。一旦你超出了薪资带，它实际上仍然可以被批准，但它需要更高、更高的级别，对吧？所以，你知道，如果你有马克·扎克伯格的批准，你可以得到1亿美元的报价。这显然超出了薪资带。所以在某种程度上你可以得到无限的报价，但把它想象成
rings of an oak tree, right? Like you have to go more and more into the inner circle of the oak tree, more to the most senior people, most trusted people at the company to get that kind of an offer. And so,
橡树的年轮，对吧？你必须进入橡树的内圈，进入公司最资深、最受信任的人那里才能得到那样的报价。所以，
and so like that's where a lot of the sort of intangible things really matters. So, for example, we talked about being committed to that offer. But another thing is, you know, let the recruiter know, like, what are the intangibles? You know, it's like, look, I really like that your company has a lot of data. You know, your company collects a lot of data, and you know so much. And knowledge is power and just the ability to kind of work with that data is kind of really uniquely interesting to me. Like, find out, and this is something you should really do at the beginning.
所以这就是很多无形的东西真正重要的地方。例如，我们谈到了对那个报价的承诺。但另一件事是，你知道，让招聘人员知道，什么是无形的？你知道，这就像，看，我真的很喜欢你们公司有很多数据。你知道，你们公司收集了很多数据，而且你知道得很多。知识就是力量，仅仅是能够处理这些数据的能力对我来说就非常独特且有趣。比如，找出，这是你应该在开始时真正做的事情。
But if you already have a job, why are you changing jobs? And if the answer is just for more money, then that's kind of a little bit difficult. Yeah, you know, yeah. Yeah, I mean, it's because you're taking on so much risk of maybe your boss isn't that great. Or maybe, you know, you don't have the kind of upward mobility. So the reality is like you really need to have good reasons for taking that job. And so when you're negotiating your compensation, you know, bringing in all those other things is really going to strengthen your case. And a nice one would be the stagnation and the problems at your current company just don't leave you as challenged and as curious as you used to be.
但如果你已经有一份工作，你为什么要换工作？如果答案只是为了更多的钱，那有点困难。是的，你知道，是的。是的，我的意思是，因为你承担了太多的风险，也许你的老板没那么好。或者也许，你知道，你没有那种向上流动的空间。所以现实是，你真的需要有充分的理由去接受那份工作。所以当你谈判薪酬时，你知道，引入所有那些其他东西真的会加强你的理由。一个很好的理由是，你当前公司的停滞和问题让你不再像以前那样感到挑战和好奇。
I've had a great time here. I've really enjoyed my time here. but I'm waking up just not nearly as excited about what we're working on. And we have a number of products that are now on hold. We're not doing any new releases. And just my experience with your company, wow, you guys have three products that you're going to be delivering inside the next nine months. I just love what you guys are doing. I find the challenges from a work standpoint.
我在这里度过了一段美好的时光。我真的很享受在这里的时光。但我醒来时对我们正在做的事情并没有那么兴奋。我们有许多产品现在处于搁置状态。我们没有做任何新的发布。而我与你们公司的经历，哇，你们有三个产品将在未来九个月内交付。我真的很喜欢你们正在做的事情。我从工作角度发现了挑战。
Waking up day to day, excited about our job is one of the greatest luxuries we can earn in our career. and you can let that company know you feel that. You realize that through the interview process. Yeah, yeah, totally. So I have a few rapid-fire things here. So one is, what's your take on moving to the coast? So there's sort of three areas on this spectrum. So one area is, you know, sort of not to move and stay where you are.
每天醒来，对我们的工作感到兴奋是我们职业生涯中能获得的最大奢侈之一。你可以让那家公司知道你的感受。你在面试过程中意识到了这一点。是的，是的，完全正确。所以我这里有几个快速回答的问题。所以一个是，你对搬到沿海地区有什么看法？所以在这个光谱上有三个领域。所以一个领域是，你知道，某种程度上不搬家，留在你所在的地方。
another one is, you know, move for the job, if it presents itself. And then the third one is move to the coast now and then look for a job. And so what's your kind of take on those three options? All you, Patrick, I'll follow up. I mean, this is such a personal question. I mean, my take is like in general, if you know having an opportunity in like the bay area new york there maybe are a few other areas where there's lots of tech companies especially early like it's always really hard to move but
另一个是，你知道，如果机会出现，为了工作搬家。然后第三个是现在搬到沿海地区，然后找工作。所以你对这三个选项有什么看法？帕特里克，你先来，我随后。我的意思是，这是一个非常私人的问题。我的看法是，总的来说，如果你知道在湾区、纽约等地有机会，也许还有其他一些有很多科技公司的地方，特别是早期，搬家总是非常困难，但
it only ever gets harder and so if you're open to doing it i mean it's i see it is it's sort of an investment and that's something you have to make with your your family spouse kids parents if there's situations and so and those things do change over time and so i i say it's sounds cheesy, but no amount of money is going to make a, like, how many people have the story of, yeah, I know a, I know the divorced VP, right? It's like, oh, the VP did great. They climbed the ladder, but they got divorced twice, three times. Like, we just, we know a brand new, uh, we know a brand new divorce CEO if you've been following. No, go to co-play concerts. That's right. Yeah. Oh, that's everywhere. Coldplay just made, uh, cold play just made two singles.
它只会变得越来越难。所以如果你愿意这样做，我的意思是，我把它看作是一种投资，这是你必须与你的家人、配偶、孩子、父母（如果有情况的话）一起做出的决定。而且这些事情确实会随时间变化。所以我说这听起来很俗气，但再多的钱也不会让，有多少人有这样的故事，是的，我知道一个，我知道那个离婚的副总裁，对吧？就像，哦，副总裁做得很好。他们爬上了阶梯，但他们离婚了两次、三次。就像，我们只是，我们知道一个全新的，呃，我们知道一个全新的离婚CEO，如果你一直在关注的话。不，去听酷玩乐队的演唱会。那是对的。是的。哦，到处都是。酷玩乐队刚刚制作了，呃，酷玩乐队刚刚制作了两首单曲。
oh gosh good call okay but but we really do know this right like people who get like i don't know i do i i i know this story directors and they you know anyways so you got to be real about that and i think to me that is something you have to figure out sort of first but in terms of like career potential i mean there's just something to be said for the fact that like there's so much opportunity next to each other it removes so much of a hassle it's more companies are willing to say well you're already here, therefore, like, we are more willing to take a swing on interviewing you because, you know, we don't have to deal with a lot of stuff. So I mean, I think earlier in the career, if it's something that you and your loved ones can kind of like get behind. Yeah,
哦天哪，好提议，好的。但但我们确实知道这一点，对吧？就像那些得到，我不知道，我确实，我确实知道这个故事，总监们，他们，无论如何，所以你必须对此保持现实。而且我认为对我来说，这是你必须首先弄清楚的事情。但就职业潜力而言，我的意思是，事实是，因为有很多机会彼此相邻，它消除了很多麻烦，这确实值得一提。更多的公司愿意说，好吧，你已经在这里了，因此，我们更愿意冒险面试你，因为，你知道，我们不必处理很多事情。所以我的意思是，我认为在职业生涯早期，如果这是你和你的亲人可以支持的事情。是的，
it really does make a big difference. I mean, I think this is same as for you, Jason, as for me, working in a non-tech hub and then going to a tech hub made an enormous difference, you know, in just like career opportunity and potential. Yeah. just I'll double down and then we'll talk to Mark. I think moving before you have a job, terrible idea. I think that, you know, I've had several people ask me that recently, even after we did the show, kind of like, you know, pressing on that. It's true.
它确实有很大的不同。我的意思是，我认为这和你一样，杰森，对我来说，在非科技中心工作然后去科技中心工作产生了巨大的不同，你知道，在职业机会和潜力方面。是的，我只是会加倍强调，然后我们和马克谈谈。我认为在有工作之前搬家，是个糟糕的主意。我认为，你知道，最近有几个人问我这个问题，即使在我们做了节目之后，某种程度上，你知道，在那个问题上施压。这是真的。
There's a ton of meetups. There's not that many meetups in, I won't say the name of the city, but the city of the person who was from, not as many meetups, but honestly, like, especially if you're junior, companies kind of expect that you're going to be able to move or they're going to give you the benefit of the doubt there. And so I don't think a Bay Area company is going to ignore you if you don't live there right now. On the flip side, you're saving a ton of money by not living in San Francisco without a job. So with that said, I think, you know, if you are, you know, if you're like relatively junior and you don't have, you know, a lot of commitments in your current city,
有很多聚会。在那个城市里没有那么多聚会，我不会说出那个城市的名字，但那个人的城市，聚会没那么多，但老实说，特别是如果你是资浅的，公司会期望你能够搬家，或者他们会给你受益的怀疑。所以我认为湾区公司不会因为你现在不住在那里而忽视你。另一方面，通过在没有工作的情况下不住在旧金山，你省下了一大笔钱。话虽如此，我认为，你知道，如果你是，你知道，如果你相对资浅，而且你没有，你知道，在你目前的城市有很多承诺，
you know, you don't have to take care of an elderly, you know, family member or, or have children who, you know, have an anchor where you're at. Yeah, moving to the coast is just like a phenomenal for your career. And I think that, you know, Patrick and I definitely wouldn't be where we are without having done that. Yeah. Good point. And, you know, for some people, two, art networks mean a lot. When you do move, take inventory of the fact that you are leaving a community of people that know a great deal about you that speak very highly of you. You might be going to a new landscape. Granted, your experience at companies and whatnot might override that. But again, for both of you, just imagine the incredible value of the
你知道，你不需要照顾年长的家庭成员，或者没有孩子，你知道，有锚点在你所在的地方。是的，搬到沿海地区对你的职业生涯来说简直太棒了。而且我认为，你知道，帕特里克和我绝对不会有今天的成就，如果不是因为我们那样做了。是的。好观点。而且，你知道，对有些人来说，两个艺术网络意味着很多。当你搬家时，盘点一下你正在离开一个非常了解你、对你评价很高的人群社区的事实。你可能正在进入一个新的景观。当然，你在公司等的经历可能会覆盖这一点。但再次强调，对你们俩来说，想象一下那种不可思议的价值。
networks you've built and the places where you've worked. And if either one of you left, like Jason, if you left Austin now and went to Rest in Virginia, you might know a couple of folks or some stuff. But wow, damn, dude. Yeah. Yeah, I think it makes sense. I think, you know, this is a sunk cost fallacy because, you know, we had COVID and during COVID time, you know, you couldn't even, you couldn't shake anyone's hand. And so it really leveled the playing field. And so, you know, Patrick and I both moved in the middle of COVID. There's other people who are who are living in, yeah, in West Virginia who could get the same tech job and have exactly same experience with someone in downtown
你建立的人脉网络以及你工作过的地方。如果你们俩中的任何一个人离开了，比如杰森，如果你现在离开奥斯汀去弗吉尼亚州的雷斯顿，你可能认识几个人或者了解一些情况。但是，天哪，伙计。是的。是的，我认为这说得通。我认为，你知道，这是一种沉没成本谬误，因为，你知道，我们经历了新冠疫情，在疫情期间，你知道，你甚至无法与任何人握手。所以这确实拉平了竞争环境。所以，你知道，帕特里克和我都是在疫情期间搬家的。还有其他人住在，是的，在西弗吉尼亚州，他们可以得到同样的技术工作，并拥有与市中心的人完全相同的经验
SF. In fact, probably just completely better because you, you, um, because a lot of the things in West Virginia didn't shut down. So like, you have child care and these other things. So you're actually like strictly better off at West Virginia in mid-2020 than downtown
旧金山。事实上，可能完全更好，因为你，你，嗯，因为西弗吉尼亚州的很多东西并没有关闭。所以，你有托儿服务和其他这些东西。所以你在2020年中期在西弗吉尼亚州实际上比在市中心要好得多
stuff. Yeah, that's, that's the past. And kind of like we talked about with job titles, you know, you can't, you can't hold yourself. You can't compare yourself to a version of you that existed in 2020. You know, you're not being fair to yourself. Like, this is the era we're in now. The COVID era is over. Totally different world. Totally different world. Yeah. And we just, you just have to have to adapt or either adapt or adapt your expectations. Either one. Love it. Um, all right. So, oh, Mark. Yeah, nice, man. Yes. What's up? What interview
东西。是的，那是，那是过去。就像我们谈论职位头衔时所说的那样，你知道，你不能，你不能固步自封。你不能拿自己与2020年存在的那个版本的自己进行比较。你知道，这对你自己不公平。就像，这是我们现在所处的时代。新冠时代已经结束了。完全不同的世界。完全不同的世界。是的。我们只是，你只需要去适应，要么适应，要么调整你的期望。两者皆可。太棒了。嗯，好的。那么，哦，马克。是的，不错，伙计。是的。怎么了？什么面试
horror stories. Oh, for people don't know, Mark has a blog. I'll put it in this show notes. It's amazing. I've literally read every post in your blog. Phenomenal. But just share like, you know, a few interview horror stories that you've heard
恐怖故事。哦，对于不知道的人，马克有一个博客。我会把它放在节目说明里。太棒了。我真的读过你博客里的每一篇文章。非凡。但只要分享一下，你知道，你听说过的一些面试恐怖故事
of that are kind of a little bit funny or informational. Well, again, one was a very talented software engineer on the initial interview with the hiring manager. Wanted confirmation on the salary, what their title would be, and how many times they'd have to come into the office.
那些有点好笑或有信息量的故事。嗯，再说一次，其中一个是关于一位非常有才华的软件工程师在与招聘经理的初次面试中。想要确认薪水、他们的头衔会是什么，以及他们必须去办公室多少次。
So immediate negotiation, and that candidate wound up getting declined. They really didn't talk too much about their technical background at all or anything like that. So the first interview is always you're just a sense of service to that hiring manager. Whatever is asked of you, you deliver on it, you let them drive the conversation. So our horror stories, to your point, Jason, or, well, how many times do that to come into the office? What's going to be my title? And I am looking for $195K-based salary. First interview dropping that hard requirement.
所以是立即谈判，那个候选人最终被拒绝了。他们真的根本没有谈论太多关于他们的技术背景或类似的事情。所以第一次面试总是你对招聘经理的服务意识。无论要求你做什么，你都要交付，你让他们主导对话。所以我们的恐怖故事，说到点子上了，杰森，或者，嗯，去办公室多少次？我的头衔会是什么？我正在寻找195K的基本工资。第一次面试就抛出那个硬性要求。
Hey, you know what? I'd say, see you later. Yeah. Yeah. We had a candidate recently after two rounds in. He goes, oh, I changed my mind. I want to be fully remote. That's kind of a horror story.
嘿，你知道吗？我会说，再见。是的。是的。我们最近有一位候选人在两轮面试后。他说，哦，我改变主意了。我想完全远程办公。那算是一种恐怖故事。
And the company just kind of froze. So the whole process is frozen. And we were walking into the final onsite. Yeah. That's interesting. first call your sense of service to that company because you applied to that company you're interested in working there you'd consider it you're at their mercy you're at their service whatever they ask of you you deliver and you let them run the show all the way up to the offer stage
公司就有点僵住了。所以整个过程冻结了。而我们正要进入最后的现场面试。是的。这很有趣。第一次通话是你对那家公司的服务意识，因为你申请了那家公司，你有兴趣在那里工作，你会考虑它，你受制于他们，你为他们服务，无论他们要求你做什么，你都要交付，并让他们在拿到录用通知之前掌控局面
and then you could kind of start interviewing them you could turn the tables a tad secure their best offer find out pTO the benefits and do that itemized if then in our personal and professional lives, when you say you're going to do three things at that other party will just do this one thing, it's quite often pretty successful. Yeah. I have an interview kind of slash post-interview horror story where we interviewed somebody and they were just extremely particular about all these details, 401K, all of these like, can I do a Roth IRA backdoor conversion? And I'm just like, I'm like, I really don't know. I can find out for you. And then we hire. them because they had great credentials, they passed the technical part of the interview. But honestly,
然后你可以开始面试他们，你可以稍微扭转局面，确保他们最好的录用条件，找出带薪休假、福利，并逐项进行。如果我们在个人和职业生活中，当你答应在那个聚会上做三件事时，对方只会做这一件事，这通常是非常成功的。是的。我有一个面试，或者说面试后的恐怖故事，我们面试了一个人，他们对所有这些细节都非常挑剔，401K，所有这些，比如，我可以做罗斯个人退休账户（Roth IRA）的后门转换吗？我只是，我只是，我真的不知道。我可以为你查一下。然后我们雇佣了他们，因为他们有很好的资历，他们通过了面试的技术部分。但老实说，
in the back of my mind, I was thinking this was a mistake. I just couldn't articulate it well enough even to myself because they did have such great credentials. So we hired them. And I remember the first week, they were upset because the employee handbook was a wiki. And so because it was a wiki, HR could edit it at any time and and they they were like well what if you edit the the handbook to make a rule that I don't agree with and uh you know and they gave a ridiculous example they said well what if you uh I'm just going to pretend their name is Mark what if you what if what if HR changes the handbook so marks aren't allowed at the company right and I was like okay here's the deal like I get it you know I hear you I said but but that's just not going to happen like
在我的脑海里，我以为这是一个错误。我只是无法很好地表达出来，即使是对我自己，因为他们确实有很好的资历。所以我们雇佣了他们。我记得第一周，他们很不高兴，因为员工手册是一个维基（wiki）。所以因为它是维基，人力资源部可以随时编辑它，他们就像，好吧，如果你编辑手册来制定一个我不同意的规则怎么办？呃，你知道，他们举了一个荒谬的例子，他们说，好吧，如果你，我只是假装他们的名字是马克，如果你，如果人力资源部修改手册，规定公司不允许有马克怎么办？我当时就想，好吧，情况是这样的，我明白了，你知道，我听到了，我说，但这根本不会发生，因为
HR is going to act in the best interest of the company. I'm trying to explain it. And it just, it just, they were really upset. We went to HR. They wanted HR to like give them a physical copy of the handbook and sign it. And they just end up letting this person go.
人力资源部会以公司的最大利益行事。我试图解释它。而且它只是，它只是，他们真的很不高兴。我们去了人力资源部。他们想让人力资源部给他们一份手册的纸质副本并签字。他们最终还是让这个人走了。
And so, you know, that's a horror story where this person was difficult, you know, because of their brilliance, we hired them anyways. And then because they were just so difficult, we have to let them go.
所以，你知道，这是一个恐怖故事，这个人很难相处，你知道，因为他们的才华，我们还是雇佣了他们。然后因为他们太难相处了，我们不得不让他们走。
And like we all know, we've all three of us have experienced it before. Things can start out. really well with another party, another human, but as you settle in with them, you start to realize, wow, we don't have a match here. And that happens a lot in the tech industry. Someone can pass either one of your interviews and they settled in. And then six weeks later, like, oh, my gosh, what has happened? You know, we sometimes do discover real individuals later on. So I, another thing, just try to be as real as possible in the interview process and the consistency, consistency of your
就像我们都知道的那样，我们三个人以前都经历过。事情开始时与另一个人，另一个人相处得很好，但当你与他们安定下来时，你开始意识到，哇，我们这里不匹配。这在科技行业经常发生。有人可以通过你们任何一个人的面试，然后他们安定下来。然后六周后，就像，哦，天哪，发生了什么？你知道，我们有时确实会在以后发现真实的人。所以我，另一件事，尽量在面试过程中尽可能真实，以及你的一致性，你的一致性
human actions and whatnot. I mean, Jason, with your incredible, brilliance and insights, you probably smelled a couple of things on this person, but just like an athlete that runs a 4-2-40, you almost got seduced by that technical brilliance. Like, whoa, wow. Yeah. This person could deliver on anything, and it overrode, you know, all the other concerns. I mean, yeah, look at some of the athletes in the NFL and the NBA. They just go and raise hell, but they blew it out in the tryouts, so the team brought them on. Yeah. Yeah. Patrick, what's a horror story from your side either you interviewing or someone you interviewing being oh dude yeah me interview i've had a lot but uh i interviewed someone one time and ah horror stories maybe a bit of a stretch
人类行为等等。我的意思是，杰森，以你令人难以置信的才华和洞察力，你可能在这个人身上闻到了一些东西，但就像一个跑4秒2的运动员，你几乎被那种技术才华所诱惑。就像，哇，哇。是的。这个人可以交付任何东西，它覆盖了，你知道，所有其他担忧。我的意思是，是的，看看NFL和NBA的一些运动员。他们只是去制造混乱，但他们在试训中表现出色，所以球队带上了他们。是的。是的。帕特里克，你那边有什么恐怖故事吗？无论是你面试别人还是别人面试你，哦，伙计，是的，我面试过很多人，但呃，我曾经面试过一个人，啊，恐怖故事可能有点夸张
um we've had them just go really bad and then the debate i'm a proponent of like from conducting interviews even if a person bombs the first couple even if you have to send in sort of like new hires to practice interviewing or whatever you still complete the interview panel but other people were pushing like no to send them home like they're done after one or tell you this is a waste of everyone's time don't waste anymore um i think there's like a respect you got to have there but but but i do hear it um but the only one i had is i had a person one time we were interviewing who just like insisted my question like they didn't want to answer my question but i asked a question like and i always am very upfront hey this is contrived is just to make sure you understand how to program
嗯，我们遇到过他们表现真的很糟糕的情况，然后辩论，我是那种主张从进行面试的人，即使一个人前几次搞砸了，即使你必须派像新员工去练习面试什么的，你仍然要完成面试小组，但其他人却在推动，比如不，送他们回家，比如他们在一次之后就完了，或者告诉你这是在浪费大家的时间，不要再浪费了，嗯，我认为那里有一种你必须有的尊重，但但但我确实听到了，嗯，但我唯一的一个是，我曾经有一个人，我们在面试，他只是坚持我的问题，就像他们不想回答我的问题，但我问了一个问题，就像，我总是非常坦率，嘿，这是人为设计的，只是为了确保你了解如何编程
um you know so you feel free to ask any question whatever and they're like you wouldn't do it this way. And I'm like, yeah, you know, I agree. That's fine. But like, let's just do it this way, like this constraint for the purpose of this. Well, this is why we invented, you know, GPUs. And I'm like, okay, well, you know, but I'm trying to see like, do you understand, you know, like, you know, how that works? Like, I agree with you. No, I'm just going to talk about how GPUs work. I'm like, okay. That's not really, they just like really get. And I, you know, I tried again. I mean, another question, you know, like, hey, what about this? Just really trying to engage them and just like every turn it was like no well of course i would only like use
嗯，你知道，所以你可以随意问任何问题什么的，他们就像，你不会这样做的。我当时就想，是的，你知道，我同意。没关系。但就像，让我们就这样做，比如为了这个目的的这个限制。好吧，这就是为什么我们发明了，你知道，GPU。我当时就想，好吧，你知道，但我试图看看，你知道，你是否理解，你知道，它是如何工作的？就像，我同意你的观点。不，我只是要谈谈GPU是如何工作的。我当时就想，好吧。那真的不是，他们只是真的很明白。而且我，你知道，我又试了一次。我的意思是，另一个问题，你知道，比如，嘿，这个怎么样？只是真的试图让他们参与进来，就像每一个转折点，就像不，好吧，当然我只会使用
the stl hash map because it's you know that's that's the thing and i you know that's how it works and i'm like yeah but do you know like if you were to write your own hash map how whatever that's a horrible idea you should never write your own they said that to you patrick and i'm like well i generally agree you should have write your own cryptography don't write your own hash maps yeah yeah yeah i agree but for the sake of like exploration and curiosity can you sort of tell me how how you would make this part of it work. Yeah, I would go to, you know, the source code for STL and I would copy the algorithm. Thank you. Patrick, for anyone that does that, I mean, yeah, you can put in the applicant tracking system never engage with this candidate. And you can win in the long run. And then
STL哈希映射，因为它是，你知道，那是，那是那回事，而且我，你知道，这就是它的工作方式，我当时就想，是的，但你知道，如果你要写你自己的哈希映射，无论那是一个多么糟糕的主意，你不应该写你自己的，他们对你说了，帕特里克，我当时就想，好吧，我通常同意你不应该写你自己的加密，不要写你自己的哈希映射，是的，是的，我同意，但为了探索和好奇心，你能告诉我你会如何让这部分工作吗。是的，我会去，你知道，STL的源代码，我会复制算法。谢谢。帕特里克，对于任何这样做的人，我的意思是，是的，你可以把申请人跟踪系统里永远不要与这个候选人接触。而且你可以从长远来看获胜。然后
your network will never engage with that person. No. Yeah. My thing is what Mark kind of pointed out. And I try to tell this when I talk to other people about how I want interviews done, you know, on my team like this is really look for a person who's curious like a person who's curious a person who has energy and drive and these are really vague and they can get into issues and then you know i'm kind of hand-waving those but like looking to say does this person want to engage with the team do they have a passion and it comes across by them asking questions i really like the work you do what about this part how do you guys think about this where do you think the future is going here you know those kinds of questions really says this person is going to bring an energy and if they bring an energy it's
你的网络将永远不会与那个人接触。不。是的。我的事情是马克指出的那种。当我与其他人谈论我希望如何进行面试时，我试图告诉这一点，你知道，在我的团队里，就像这真的是寻找一个好奇的人，一个好奇的人，一个有活力和动力的人，这些真的很模糊，他们可能会陷入问题，然后你知道，我有点挥手告别那些，但就像寻找说，这个人想与团队互动吗？他们有热情吗？这通过他们问问题表现出来，我真的很喜欢你做的工作，这部分怎么样？你们是怎么想这个的？你认为未来会走向哪里？你知道，这些问题真的说明这个人会带来一种能量，如果他们带来一种能量，它
going to overcome whatever other minor perturances that happened because on day one, you know, we couldn't get the credentials for their login sorted, right? If they're already like, I only took this because it was 3% more than my current job. Oh, yeah, this is not going to work. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I agree 100% Patrick. Yeah, I'm sorry about that. But damn. No, you don't have to apologize. It wasn't you. It turns out there's really weird bad people in the world. It's like, no, no, there is. And it's getting a little bit worse. Our social dynamics and social connections are struggling, bro. And now they're starting to invent AI tools to be friends with people.
将克服发生的任何其他轻微的干扰，因为在第一天，你知道，我们无法整理他们的登录凭据，对吧？如果他们已经像，我只接受这个，因为它比我目前的工作多3%。哦，是的，这行不通。是的。是的。是的。我100%同意帕特里克。是的，我很抱歉。但是该死。不，你不必道歉。那不是你。事实证明，世界上确实有非常奇怪的坏人。就像，不，不，确实有。而且情况变得有点糟糕。我们的社会动态和社会联系正在挣扎，兄弟。现在他们开始发明人工智能工具来与人交朋友。
Oh, my. No, no, no, no, no. We'll run way too long. Well, that's actually a good segue to my last question that I have on here, which is, how do you deal with fake candidates? Because I've heard this from the person has like 100 jobs. Yeah. Oh, yeah, yeah, that's right.
哦，我的。不，不，不，不，不。我们会跑得太远。嗯，这实际上是我在这里提出的最后一个问题的一个很好的过渡，那就是，你如何处理虚假的候选人？因为我从那个人有100份工作那里听说过。是的。哦，是的，是的，那是对的。
So, like, I'm currently, we're not hiring at circuit. You know, we're still trying to build out the product at PMS. product market fit and all this stuff. But there's another team inside circuit that is hiring and they're just getting flooded with fake people. And the resumes look good. And it says, oh, this person went to Georgia Tech and they didn't actually go to Georgia Tech. And even the interview, the Zoom call is like deep faked. It's just out of control. So Mark, you might have more breadth on this. Like, you could pick us off. Like, how do you deal with fake interviewers? that is something that is somewhat sadly beyond our control. When a company post jobs,
所以，比如，我目前，我们在Circuit没有招聘。你知道，我们还在努力构建PMS的产品。产品市场契合度以及所有这些东西。但Circuit内部有另一个团队正在招聘，他们只是被虚假的人淹没了。简历看起来不错。上面说，哦，这个人去了佐治亚理工学院，但他们实际上并没有去佐治亚理工学院。甚至面试，Zoom通话就像深度伪造的。这简直失控了。所以马克，你可能在这方面有更多的广度。比如，你可以挑选我们。比如，你如何处理虚假的面试官？这在某种程度上令人悲伤地超出了我们的控制。当一家公司发布工作时，
the fake AI applicants are submitting resumes in large volume. We're getting a number of fake ones too, but then we just shut them right down. So that is one benefit. Perhaps when your company is interviewing maybe some internal recruiters, that can be part of their responsibility to go in there and vet out all of these fake applicants. That's a lot of work, but that saves you a ton of time. something my agency, when I work with firms, we make it clear, hey, we don't send it over any robotic fake candidates or anything like that. We qualify on all of them. They're willingness to come into the office a whole nine yards. But direct applications, Jason, damn it, bro, I'm sorry, you're going to get a ton of fake applicants in there, but maybe make
虚假的人工智能申请人正在大量提交简历。我们也收到了一些虚假的，但我们只是直接关闭了它们。所以这是一个好处。也许当你的公司在面试时，也许是一些内部招聘人员，这可以成为他们职责的一部分，去那里审查所有这些虚假的申请人。这工作量很大，但这为你节省了大量时间。我代理机构的一些事情，当我与公司合作时，我们明确表示，嘿，我们不会发送任何机器人虚假候选人或类似的东西。我们对他们所有人进行资格审查。他们进入办公室的意愿，全套服务。但直接申请，杰森，该死，兄弟，我很抱歉，你会收到大量的虚假申请人，但也许确保
sure that internal recruiter cuts through all those so you don't have to mess with it because that would be a massive waste of your time. Yeah. So, you know, without revealing any secrets here, How do you do that? Is it through, like, following their LinkedIn and all of that? We have. I've spoken with candidates. Their name's Kevin Thompson. And then it's a deep, deep, deep Ukrainian accent.
那个内部招聘人员切断了所有这些，这样你就不必处理它了，因为那将是对你时间的巨大浪费。是的。所以，你知道，在不透露任何秘密的情况下，你是怎么做到的？是通过，比如，关注他们的领英和所有这些吗？我们有。我与候选人交谈过。他们的名字叫凯文·汤普森。然后是一个深，深，深乌克兰口音。
So it is, it's offshore. And it's, yeah, it's something else. I'd be like, whoa, this is Kevin. You're from Louisville, Kentucky. But what's the economic incentive? Like, what are they, what is their end goal? Like, to try to get a virtual position and not. work it? It could be contributing a cyber crime. It could be individuals over in Europe hoping that
所以它是，它是离岸的。而且它是，是的，它是别的东西。我会说，哇，这是凯文。你来自肯塔基州路易斯维尔。但经济激励是什么？比如，他们，他们的最终目标是什么？比如，试图获得一个虚拟职位而不去工作？它可能是参与网络犯罪。它可能是欧洲的个人希望
individual does get hired in a fully remote role. And actually, and then you've got a team over there doing the coding and whatnot. It's a fake human. They try to get away with that. And you're paying that person a hundred forty thousand dollars a year. You can't tell if that's happening. Maybe it's okay. Not in a crime way. That's bad. But like, yeah. It's failing terribly, though. Fake AI candidates and whatnot. Fake bots. They're not getting jobs. But they are, you know, people are, hell, we all get hit up constantly by cybercriminals. It's a lot of the cyber crime fails terribly. And trying to get fake AI bots into software engineering positions orchestrated from foreign countries is not working.
个人确实在完全远程的角色中被录用。实际上，然后你有一个团队在那里做编码什么的。这是一个虚假的人。他们试图逃脱惩罚。而你每年付给那个人十四万美元。你无法判断这是否正在发生。也许没关系。不是以犯罪的方式。那很糟糕。但就像，是的。虽然它失败得很惨。虚假的人工智能候选人什么的。虚假机器人。他们没有得到工作。但他们是，你知道，人们是，该死，我们都被网络犯罪分子不断地骚扰。很多网络犯罪失败得很惨。试图将虚假的人工智能机器人放入从外国策划的软件工程职位中是行不通的。
Yeah. Yeah, I think that they're for tax and other reasons. Like a lot of companies, even though they're hiring remote, will only hire in North America or in Western Hemisphere or what have you. And so they're just trying to circumvent that. by masquerading. I think that the bigger problem isn't necessarily that they're from Ukraine, it's that they've lied on their resume, that they said, oh, I went to, you know, Georgia Tech, and they didn't actually go to Georgia Tech. You know, one thing that is surprising to me is how few companies do background checks. You know, it's only like, I think, $50 or something to do a
是的。是的，我认为他们是因为税收和其他原因。比如很多公司，即使他们正在招聘远程，也只会雇佣北美或西半球或什么的。所以他们只是试图规避这一点。通过伪装。我认为更大的问题不一定是他们来自乌克兰，而是他们在简历上撒谎了，他们说，哦，我去了，你知道，佐治亚理工学院，而他们实际上并没有去佐治亚理工学院。你知道，有一件事让我感到惊讶，就是很少有公司进行背景调查。你知道，我认为只有，我想，50美元左右去做一个
background. So we actually, you know, my wife and I own a small kind of event space and we do background checks on the employees, but you hear so many stories of people being ambuseled by, you know, AI workers in the Ukraine or something like that. And I feel like a background check should catch that every time. Another neat thing about certain areas here in Austin, as both of you will know, if someone worked at Retail Me Not from 2010 to 14, and then KOROS and then CS Disco till 2025 and I've met that person in person, then we'd be good. So there are the small exceptions.
背景。所以我们实际上，你知道，我和我妻子拥有一家小型活动空间，我们对员工进行背景调查，但你听到太多关于人们被乌克兰的人工智能工作者或其他类似的人伏击的故事。我觉得背景调查应该每次都能抓住这一点。奥斯汀这里某些地区的另一件整洁的事情，正如你们俩都知道的那样，如果有人在2010年到14年在Retail Me Not工作，然后是KOROS，然后是CS Disco直到2025年，而且我亲自见过那个人，那么我们就会很好。所以有这些小的例外。
And that's something we can appreciate in terms of the strength of our networks. But you're right, Jason. There's a lot of background checks are not being done when they should be. Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense. Patrick, have you ever had to interview a fake person?
这是我们可以欣赏的，就我们网络的强度而言。但你是对的，杰森。当应该进行背景调查时，很多背景调查并没有被进行。是的。是的，这说得通。帕特里克，你有没有不得不面试一个虚假的人？
Not that ever made it. Not that I know of. Is that the correct answer? Like, is that like asking me, am I an android? And not that I know of? Well, what about a resume? Did you ever see a resume? And later on you found out it was fake or anything like that?
没有成功过。据我所知没有。那是正确的答案吗？就像，这就像问我，我是机器人吗？据我所知没有？好吧，简历呢？你有没有见过简历？后来你发现它是假的或类似的东西？
I mean, we've seen resumes before that, yeah, I, but you kind of can tell, I don't know, like, there's certain giveaways that are something is like nonsensical or, you know, oh, wait, hang on this. Yeah, so I've seen resumes that were clearly, I know, I hesitate to attribute to malice what can be attributed to stupidity. But, you know, yeah. But I think to Mark's point, I mean, in general, I work at a big company. And so I don't do a lot of first-line screening of, I only normally get resumes from people I know or from other humans, which generally tend to be better quality. And then the recruiters screen out most of the others. That makes sense. Nice.
我的意思是，我们以前见过简历，是的，我，但你有点能看出来，我不知道，比如，有一些赠品是某些东西是无意义的，或者，你知道，哦，等等，等等这个。是的，所以我见过简历，显然，我知道，我犹豫是否将可以归因于愚蠢的事情归因于恶意。但是，你知道，是的。但我认为马克说得对，我的意思是，总的来说，我在一家大公司工作。所以我没有做很多第一线的筛选，我通常只从我认识的人或其他人那里得到简历，这通常往往质量更好。然后招聘人员筛选掉大多数其他人。这说得通。不错。
Cool. This was awesome, guys. I loved it, Jason. Yeah, thank you so much, Mark. Really quick, do you have something you want to plug, a website or a Twitter handle or anything like that? Oh, no, we're nothing. It's kind of neat. We've just got a good brand.
酷。这太棒了，伙计们。我喜欢它，杰森。是的，非常感谢你，马克。真的很快，你有什么想推广的吗，网站或推特账号或类似的东西？哦，不，我们什么都没有。这有点整洁。我们只是有一个好的品牌。
This is going to crack you guys up. You know, you do it through the years. Our client, we've got to keep them confidential, but they're bringing us on. They've got an engineering organization over in China. And it was a couple of engineers were just talking in China about finding a recruiting firm in the U.S. They thought of our firm.
这会让你们笑出来的。你知道，你多年来一直这样做。我们的客户，我们必须对他们保密，但他们正在带我们加入。他们在中国的工程组织。那是几个工程师只是在中国谈论在中国寻找一家招聘公司。他们想到了我们的公司。
Oh, that's awesome. Yeah, so we love it. And again, either one of you guys hit me up any time if you just need some market data. but this was just incredible, Jason. I cannot thank you enough, bro. Greatly appreciate it. Thank you so much.
哦，那太棒了。是的，所以我们喜欢它。再说一次，你们俩中的任何一个随时联系我，如果你只需要一些市场数据。但这真是太不可思议了，杰森。我无法足够感谢你，兄弟。非常感谢。非常感谢。
All right. We'll do it. What's the name of your firm one more time? Oh, the bidding network, B-I-D-D-I-N-G network. The bidding network. Again, we're just a team of three close engineers. We're doing really well, and we love what we do. We've got a good fortune.
好的。我们会做的。你的公司名字再叫一次？哦，竞标网络，B-I-D-D-I-N-G网络。竞标网络。再说一次，我们只是一个由三名亲密工程师组成的团队。我们做得很好，我们热爱我们所做的事情。我们有很好的运气。
We provide a very genuine sense of service to our audience here in Austin. Yeah. Well, hopefully this whole episode is a testament to how much you, the collective view out there, your feedback matters people gave us a lot of feedback as I said the audience is double we usually get which is already like a very humbling number and so that we turned around and tried to give you all more more content that that you're looking for so I really hope that this answer a lot of questions if you have follow-up questions feel free to send them to me I can pass them on to mark or Patrick and everyone out there good luck on your interviewing and have a great day
我们为我们在奥斯汀的观众提供了一种非常真诚的服务意识。是的。好吧，希望这一整集证明了你们，外面的集体观点，你们的反馈有多重要，人们给了我们很多反馈，正如我所说，观众是我们通常得到的两倍，这已经是一个非常谦卑的数字，所以我们回过头来试图给你们所有人更多你们正在寻找的内容，所以我真的希望这回答了很多问题，如果你有后续问题，请随时发送给我，我可以把它们转给马克或帕特里克，祝大家面试顺利，祝你有美好的一天
Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share-A-Like 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share like and kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
音乐由埃里克·巴恩多拉（Eric Barndollar）创作。Programming Throwdown在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，重新混合、改编作品，但你必须向帕特里克和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。